and I have two wolves, you know, it's [music] the two wolves
situation. One part of me is like I think the only reason they're
looking into this is because they're race baiting, okay? But
then there's another part of me that I'm like, this is all shady
as there is some absolutely shady going on here and a lot of
people are looking at these people doing the race baiting and
they're going, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Like,
this can't possibly all this is fake." I'm like, "Dude, open
your eyes. Open your eyes.
>> Should we watch the full Somali documentary? I've not
seen [music] it. I don't even know what it is. I've I've heard
people talk about it, so I do have some idea of what's going
on there. Here, hold on. The full the original documentary right
here.
>> A little bit of this.
>> I just I listen, I've not actually checked it out. I
do want to watch it. >> Where the money's going. What do
you guys think about the fraud that's taking place here in Minnesota?
>> Sorry. I don't think anybody is enabling fad to happen.
>> Can I just ask, how are there enough Somali in Pisco
versus Connor? I've got loaded up for later. How are there enough
Somali in Minnesota that they've got like a hundred different
daycarees?
Like what is the population
that they've got like hundreds of daycarees that they opened?
Or is it just like Yeah, I I don't get
That's what makes it seem like a unique like community-based
thing is they probably just figured out you could go do like
this kind of
I would guess that it actually probably started out as oh we
should just open daycarees cuz you can get these good deals from
the government and you can run this daycare and make a lot of
money right I'm guessing that's how it probably started and then
probably somebody went wait what if we just filled out this paperwork
nobody's ever come to check
you know what I'm saying >> governor walls accountable
for this >> what was this money spent on
1.26 million. What was that money? >> There aren't any
kids. >> Answer the question. Are there children? >> There's
no children inside this >> Potentially the largest fraud
scandal in US history is taking place in Minnesota as literally
billions of dollars have been funneled through Somali ran fraudulent
businesses.
So much fraud it could actually almost replace the entire
>> That's funny. Sorry. That's that is funny though.
So much fraud we could replace the entire GDP. I thought it was
a billion in Minnesota. Is it really 9 billion now? It's up to
9 billion. I thought it was barely I thought it was 900 million
verging towards a billion and now it says 9 billion assumed here
or estimated stolen by scammers.
Federal prosecutors World Bank is Somalia. Somalia's GDP >> of
Somalia. These frauders have worked hand in hand with the min.
>> You're still in your nickly avatar. I know. But the
Nick Lee Avatar is cool. >> So the government has enabled
billions of dollars to be given to fraudulent businesses underneath
welfare purposes.
>> Why do you say business?
Why do you say fraudulent businesses?
Billions of dollars be given to fraudulent businesses underneath
welfare purposes. Some of this money eventually landed in the
hands of terrorist groups in Somalia like the Al Shabab and others
enriched themselves all at the US taxpayers expense. And in this
>> video, we'll break down all of the fraud from start
to finish, from going to the fraudulent businesses and confronting
the people who are making millions of dollars from the government.
And so I've
I've seen some of this stuff from like I think DGG went and investigated
this and they're like oh actually he went when the daycare was
closed and then somebody else came out and investigated that
investigation was like actually this daycare is supposed to be
a day daycare not a night daycare not like an evening daycare
like for your evening shift. So, actually, they're not even like
they're kind of lying about like how could they be a day daycare
like like during the normal like working hours and do 2:00 p.m.
to 10 p.m. That's weird.
I don't know. I'm waiting for the investigation of the investigation
of the >> And we will also be confronting the incompetent
government leaders who let this fraud happen. And to make this
happen, I met up with a man who's been doing his own investigation.
DG was exposed already for getting it wrong. Wrong. Wrong. He
said wrong. So
this is why we need to ill
citizen journalists.
Oh, ill. I see. No, I don't think so. I don't think so. >> For
years now as he has seen the fraud firsthand. His name is Message
David. Let's get into this and be prepared to be shocked. >> How
deep is this fraud here inside of Minnesota? It is far worse
than anybody can imagine. You heard it's 7 to 10 billion and
maybe more. And now the numbers have been revised and put out
there publicly that they think it's more like 8 billion. How
I got involved is that where my office is here in Minneapolis.
I'm sort of in the heart of all of the
This reporting has been all over CNN and I doubt they would just
run with it or run it if they thought it was completely fake.
Right.
Um, listen. They've got a lot of pictures up on these walls.
They look kind of legitimate to me. Wait, wait, wait. Nick, Nick,
Nick, should we take down the red string before these people
come in? Yeah, we should take down the red string. The red string
is a bit much. We'll leave the pictures up, though. Okay. Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Got it. Got it.
This fraud and I would see these childcare centers. I said, "Well,
there aren't any kids there. It's the middle of the day." And
all I see are a couple of guys standing out front smoking. And
then I'd go by another daycare and I'd see the same thing. I
said, "Well,
where do these kids play?"
>> Naturalb born noticer. NBN right here. Naturalb born
noticer. This guy just started noticing things and then he took
action. He's He noticed some stuff and then he noticed some more
stuff and then he's going to verify the pattern and break a story.
>> So, I started to go online and look and I said, "This
place is licensed for 80 children. They had zero children. Every
time I went by there, they never had a single child there. Then
I started to see all these transportation companies going around
and it was always a Somali driver. And I said, "Well, that's
great. They're out there transportation contributing, but they
never had a passenger. Never ever once." And I said, "Well, what
is all this transportation? What are they doing?" So then I found
out that in Minnesota
they have something called non-emergency medical
So this is going to the dentist's
therapy, whatever it might be. And I said, "Well, how many of
these companies are there?" And the research came back that there
are a,020 of them, and more than 800 of them are Somali owned.
Nobody from the state of Minnesota ever cross checks to see if
any rides were ever actually provided. All they did was write
the check. >> So, right here, we have all this
I don't trust this old guy. I I feel
no relation throwback.
Wait. Okay. If that's not related at all, I'm not going to click
on it right now. >> And how are you getting all this
>> I I'm sitting here and I'm like,
Dude, I
I could believe this exists, right? I could like the fraud actually
happened. I feel like you don't want to get into the Man, I don't
know how much of you how many of you guys have really like looked
into this. I'm seeing a lot of chatters who are just like, "Dude,
you these guys are crazy. They're racist.
Well, I don't know. The conspiracy stuff. No evidence in public
records is just this video. Wait, hold on. What did you say?
I don't trust any of this. H.
Some fraud happened. Yes. Well, I I'm cool with like Hold on.
A recent video by conservative YouTuber Nick Shirley alleged
nearly a dozen daycare centers in Minnesota that are receiving
public funds are not actually providing any service. After the
video went viral, DHS Secretary Christy Nome announced a massive
investigation on childcare and other rampant fraud in the state.
CBS News conducted its own analysis of nearly a dozen daycare
centers mentioned by Shirley. All but two have active licenses
according to state records or sorry according to state records
and all active locations were visited by state state regulators
within the last 6 months. CBS News review also found dozens of
citations related to ah related to safety, cleanliness, equipment
and staff training among other violations and there were no record
was no recorded evidence of fraud. More than 60 people have been,
according to federal prosecutors, it was really during CO that
fraudsters set up these fake restaurants or sham businesses and
health clinics that would provide things like meals to school
children or behavioral health services or housing to people with
addiction. And because during co you didn't have the same checks
and balances, you had social distancing, you
>> like here's the thing. What we need to differentiate
here is the idea that oh the Somali community might have, you
know, I know the Somali community is involved in government.
Could it have been the case that they just knew these contracts
existed, knew these programs existed, and they opted to do these
businesses because they were probably getting like favorable
contracts, favorable like payments to do these things? Like what
is the advantage of just driving an empty car when you could
be driving like a disabled person to the dentist or some [__]
Like I I don't necessarily believe this guy when he's like, "Oh,
well,
they had an empty car. They they weren't taking anybody around."
You know what I'm saying? I I just don't know why you wouldn't.
It's like if you're already making crazy money, you might as
well just do the actual job. Are they seriously alleging 9 billion?
Well, that was alleged by Fox News. Who knows under what context
or in what like Yeah, in what context it's alleged.
I can't see it being just >> You couldn't have the site
visits. You couldn't have the in-person inspections. Well, the
fraudsters got away with it all and provided the receipts and
collected boatloads of cash from us, the taxpayers.
More than 90 people have been charged in the schemes, mostly
Somali, and more than 60 people have been convicted. Now, you
have this viral video getting traction online. And it's from
influencer Nick Shirley. And he visited several daycarees, Somali
owned daycares in the Twin Cities, and basically accused them
of doing the same thing, running these sham operations where
kids didn't show up, but still build the federal government and
collected millions of dollars in Medicaid funds. We visited those
sites, too, as did state inspectors many times over the last
six months, and we found the facts on the ground tell a different
story. Those daycarees, many of them were written up for safety
violations,
things like maybe busted equipment or staff training issues,
but that's not the same as being fraudulent.
>> So, it's important to put all of this into context.
Granted, fraud is indisputably
an issue in Minnesota, and next year it's going to turn up the
heat continuously on state officials, including Minnesota Governor
Tim Walls, who's running for reelection. And there are 14 programs,
Medicaid funded programs that are currently under investigation
by state and federal government, but child care is not one of
them. >> Again, this is something we're going to keep following
well into next.
Okay. So, that's totally fine. Now, what I didn't see there was
like that investig like would you want to go look at reports
and see that they were actually taking care of kids on the day
they were going to be there? I What would you do to try to figure
out if these people had been taking care of kids for like long
periods of time? I guess it would be you'd probably want receipts
for the individual kids that they had there and then you'd want
to go visit those families and say, "Hey, do you drop your kid
off at this business?" Right. And then I guess cross check. I'm
assuming you'd have like the the kids' name listed or the the
checks from like the people paying you. You'd want to look at
the books, see who's making the payments and talk to those people,
right? Well, I'm I'm saying if you wanted to know this for sure
if you wanted to actually answer this, right? By annual checks
during business hours as well. Well, I don't doubt that they
could make it for the checks, but I'm just saying if you wanted
to like totally absolve people, I think you would try to do that
kind of investigation, right? Why not just do a stake out and
make sure they are receiving children? I'm going to assume this
wouldn't be a very hard thing to figure out. Probably not.
That's what I would like to see here is probably beyond just
like individual visits to daycarees at at times.
You'd probably want to be yes like binding daycarees that fit
the pattern and then yeah sticking them out.
So I guess we'll see if they go and attempt to do that. I'm guessing
they didn't about the fraud. A lot of it is is through my own
research and then I have some contacts at the capital going back
many many years and so the data that I'm getting is 100% accurate
coming directly from research done by people at the state >> All
this paperwork right here.
>> What are we looking at? >> The areas of fraud
that
I have numbers for are mostly related to child care. This is
massive fraud that is beyond anyone's imagination the scope.
And so for example, there's a child care not far from here in
Minneapolis that has two day two child carees listed at the same
address and together they're licensed supposedly for 120 children
together. >> Hold on. Hold on. Make child care. Same address,
same address, license, different license numbers. This person's
the owner here. I don't know if they should include all the information
of these people. It seems kind of irresponsible to just include
this person's name for no reason. You're already giving people
the ability to go look these places up. I don't know why you
would go and say like include the owner on both of them. >> They're
licensed.
>> That seems just really, really, really weird to be honest.
>> 120 children.
I have never seen a single child there ever. And I've been by
that place at least a hundred times. The
Okay.
Now, if you're going to go by that place a 100 times, I don't
like hearing that. I've been by that place a h 100 times. I don't
like randomly going by and then what are you peeking in the windows
to see if there's kids? Hey, got any kids here? Hey, got any
got any kids here? Hey, you're just peeking in windows or
I would just you you would want to sit out there. You'd want
to honestly like sit there for hours and hours and hours probably.
You'd want to see what time they open at, right? And then you'd
want to go there at the time they open and you'd want to sit
there until around the time they close. Maybe sit there for 2
hours and then around the time they close, two hours before that
you sit there for like two and a half two two and a half hours.
Right? That's the system I would like to see put into place here
to try to see if
uh people are actually getting dropped off. >> These Somalians,
these groups are setting up these daycarees, these childcare
centers, getting money from the government, but there's no kids.
>> No kids. Never had any of them. They're all fraught
with violations and even though they had these
>> Why was that cut? Why did >> they're all fraught
with violations and
>> they're all fraught with violations. And then he was
talking about something else. And >> even though they have
these violations, they're still in operation and they're still
getting money and it's millions of dollars for every one of them
every >> And who's getting the money and where are they
getting the money from? >> So we have a thing called CCAP.
It's a blend of federal and state money. The bottom line is it's
taxpayer money. So it's state money and it's federal money. And
the problem is the people of the state of Minnesota are the ones
writing the checks.
This is kind of the maddening thing is you have daycare. So you
have adult daycare and then you have child care and then you
have health care and a lot of these same names keep coming up
on all of these different types of businesses >> through
a link in the Discord to play. >> And then of course we
have the transportation. A lot of those same names appear, a
lot of the same addresses. There's one building
that has [snorts] 14
Somali healthcare companies at the same address. There's another
building in St. Paul that has 22 Somali healthc care businesses
at the same
>> And the government knows about this. >> The government
knows they're writing the checks. Yeah, the Democrats over there
writing just writing the checks. What has happened is that the
Somali community is a very closed community. They will not speak
to anyone outside the community and talk about what's going on
within the community. They vote as a block. And so when you're
a politician, you're saying, "Look, I've got 100,000 people in
Minnesota that if I do something for the community, they're going
to vote for me." And that's what it's all about is getting the
votes. And then the people here in Minnesota hear this term Minnesota
nice. I'm so sick of that term.
>> It always comes back to demonizing the Somali. True.
So, what what I would do is I'd say that's a red flag. I'm going
to double check this guy's work, right? Cuz unfortunately,
racists are capable of noticing patterns. Okay. So, I think probably
any action taking taken on just this documentary or just this
guy's work would be stupid. Okay. Obviously stupid.
But you could look into this. Um, I I'm guessing that's what
Nick Shirley wanted to do. >> People here are so afraid
of being called a racist or an Islamophobe
and they're just they're afraid of their own shadow. And I don't
understand this is our our future generations are going to have
to pay for all this fraud and they just want to bury their heads
in the sand and go on and just not worry about it. Tim Walls
saying there's organized crime in Minnesota. What did he do about
it? Nothing. You got organized crime? What do you What are you
doing? This is the Minnesota law which mandates that anyone who
knows of fraud and is a state employee must report that fraud.
It's Minnesota statute 3.971
subdivision 9. Not only that, but Walls is also guilty of misconduct
of a >> Nick Shirley is a race baiting Tyler Olivea wannabe.
Is he? He literally he literally copied Tyler Tyler Olivera's
exact thumbnail style, didn't he? This is the Tyler Olivea thumbnail
style explicitly, isn't it? Hold on. Tyler Olivea.
I'm pretty sure it's the exact thumbnail style.
Okay. Tyler Olivera does not use the yellow text though. It is
like the same thumbnail style, but it is not. The text is new
or the text is a twist. Okay. Migrants of Yeah, he is. He is
a race baiter for sure. Bro, who is
This looks like Kenneth Copeland. Except also,
Bro, why is he talking to a demon?
Who is that? I don't I don't recognize that person. That senator.
Who's that senator? They look like a demon. What the
the Connecticut Senator Blumenthal? Oh, okay. Public employees.
>> When I look at the world as whole and I look at fraud,
the Twin Cities is ground zero. The fraud is worse here than
anywhere else ever in history anywhere. >> We're gonna
go these we're gonna go to these daycare centers. We're gonna
see what what's actually happening. >> Okay. So, we have
to be careful because these people are very violent. They're
exceptionally violent >> now with Okay. Okay. [laughter]
I see where I see where you go. I see what you're cooking. I
I can
Sorry. I'm just like, dude, dude, come on, man.
>> All of David's evidence. We headed out to the streets
of Minneapolis to see how much fraud we could uncover in one
afternoon. Where are we going now? >> We're going to a
place called Makeo Child Care, which actually has another child
care registered at the same address called Mini Child Care Center.
>> So, we should see lots of children if there's a this
uh childcare center, especially if there's two. >> The
two of them combined are licensed for 120.
>> And how much money have these childcare centers received?
None of those vans have moved in 6 months. None of them. In 2020,
one of them received 1.3 million. In 2021, they got 987,000.
In 2022, they got 714,000.
That's the last I have for that one. And then the other >> money
stolen from Minnesota. Damn.
million in fiscal year. >> Oh, hold on. You guys notice
you guys notice the obvious reason that there's two licenses,
right? Hold on. Did we all notice it? Cuz it's really obvious
right there. It's on. It's just obvious. It immediately stands
out, right? Money stole from Minnesota. 2020, 2021, 2022. And
then you hit play. And this is the other license. 2023, 2024,
2025. They changed the name or rellicensed it.
like incredibly obviously, there's got to be a billion people
who pointed this out. Yeah, you guys have watched a bunch of
people watch this documentary. There's a billion people who pointed
that out. That obvious switch up right there. See, that's that
to me is like I can already validate incredibly bad methodology
from these people, right?
When you show those things right there, Atriox said this was
good journalism.
Uh, it could be good journalism maybe, but like that right there
I when I noticed that I've never seen this. I
I've never seen this and I noticed something immediately that
I'm like, "Oh, you're like kind of not you're not really paying
attention. You're kind of just like painting in a weird way."
Well, no, you're painting things in a malicious way, but you're
not really paying attention to like the stuff you're presenting.
You didn't see what happened. Okay, if you want to see So, basically,
this guy's entire premise, the first like 5 minutes of this video
or the second five minutes of this video, he's been building
up this one specific child care place saying that it is the source
of a ton of fraud. Okay? And they're like, "Oh, they have two
licenses. That's crazy. They have two licenses. Up to 120 kids
could be here, right?" And it's like, I look immediately. It's
like, "Well, I see why they have two licenses. They obviously
went to a different business." >> That's the last. >> So
2020, 2021, 2022 for the first one. >> That one. And then
the other one one
>> and then this one fiscal year 2023. So they switched
for the new fiscal year. They switched to a new name. So, like
obviously the first question would be like, hey, when you change
your name, when you update it with the state, do they maybe just
put give you a new license? Is there something with their their
software system? They give you like a new new license number
or
right? Who knows? There's there's a bunch of questions I could
ask, but clearly they're not saying there are two daycare centers
operating out of the same place. It's one stops in fiscal year
2022, the other stop or starts in fiscal year 2023. It's two
separate businesses, bro.
Okay.
But like, so maybe they didn't shut down the previous one. Maybe
somebody different incorporated it. I have no idea. But I'm saying
that clearly there isn't a concept of two different businesses
operating out of the same address getting money at the same time.
Yeah. Very very very obviously. Or they just didn't put this
this company's fiscal year 2020 2021 2022 like numbers here,
which would be odd.
You are not paying attent. I'm definitely paying attention. I
literally just gave you a an idea of what could happen that maybe
you know you go to update your business's name and you have to
update your license number. Very obvious to me,000.
That's the last I have for that one. And then the other
64 million in fiscal year 2025.
fiscal year 2024
they got about 800,000 and in 20 fiscal year 2023 they got
This place right here. >> Outside of it. >> Well,
this is actually two daycarees are registered here. One of them
is Mako which you see on this sign. The other one is Mini Child
Care Center.
And between the two of these
child care centers, they're pulling in about $3 million a year.
>> about $3 million a year.
Wait, does he maybe just not include Hold on. 23, 24, 25,
20, 21, 22. Okay, so my question was, okay, do these things operate
at the same time or do they not? So, this is showing no overlap
cuz I was thinking, oh, did they maybe just up the formatting
and this this first one kept going through 2022 to 2023 to 2024
to 2025. But there is no overlap here. I can see it from his
notes that he shows in the video. So they're not they're also
$3 million facility you go to. The windows will be blocked out
so you can't see in. >> There's nobody here. You won't
see a single child at any of these facilities.
>> By the way, he could still be right that this is like
fraudulent in some way. But I'm I'm just putting little things
together, okay, to see whether or not I trust this very much.
And so far, I don't trust this very much. Also, I'm gonna end
on Twitch, guys. Head over to kick.com/jc.
I'm heading over to kick right away. So, good luck. See you over
there in about two minutes. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye, Twitchers. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Okay, what do we do here?
We need to go and turn our kick revenue on.Oop
based.
This is just a schizophrenic racist. Um, schizophrenic racist
can notice patterns, too. I'm telling you, I don't I'm not gonna
discount this guy because he's like racist. I'm not going to
discount this guy because he is um because he's like crazy or
something. I'm gonna discount him because his work's shoddy.
That's what I'm going to do. I don't have to go I don't have
to find a way to just like, you know, thought terminate and not
listen to this guy anymore. I'll just check his work actually
or I'll see what's presented and I'll see what it tells me. There
are indeed no windows. All the windows are blacked out right
here. All right, let's go in. >> Let's go. >> And
the childcare center is locked. Should we ring the doorbell?
>> Try to get in. Rang the doorbell. Nobody showed up.
They're open 7 days a week, 7:00 a.m. to 10:00 p.m. it says here
on their sign. Yet there's absolutely nobody here. And this building
here right here has generated millions of dollars. And it seems
like business isn't even open right now and it's a weekday. And
if this was a daycare center, it wouldn't just be in some industrialized
building. There would be maybe like a playground or something
outside or >> there's no play area for the kids.
So where
>> um childc care center locked sounds like a good thing.
I mean not really. What if a parent needed to get in? Why? Why?
That sounds like something you heard from a and I heard multiple
people say it. Why would the door of a childcare center be locked?
You literally have somebody sitting at the front and people walk
in. Don't just say, "Oh, well they should have it locked. There's
kids in there." No. What if a parent is coming through to get
like Yeah. You have a lobby. If it's actually Christmas, which
it could be, I I don't know. But the idea The idea that we're
gonna keep this door locked. Oh, we locked down the Dude, that's
a lot of daycarees buzz you in. Okay. Well, they didn't get buzzed
in. Can they even Hold on. Can they even buzz you in? Only thing
I've seen like that is rehab centers. They rang a doorbell. What
was the doorbell? Oh, maybe they can. Maybe they can. Maybe that's
a lock box that
they're pulling here. Yes. You've already rang the doorbell.
Child >> blacked out right here. All right, let's go in.
>> And the childare center is locked. Should we ring the
doorbell?
>> Try to get in. Rang the doorbell. Nobody showed up.
>> Now, I will say if there's like a Nest camera somewhere
around here and these these two old guys you don't recognize
and they've got a camera and you can see that they're like literally
recording, you might go, "Oh, I don't know who that is. I'm not
answering the door."
Entirely possible. They're open 7 days a week, 7:00 a.m. to 10:00
p.m. it says here on their sign. Yet there's absolutely nobody
here. And this building here right here has generated
millions of dollars and it seems like business isn't even. So
I would say the thing you should do here, the thing you should
think about here is do I want to go sit outside of this school
for a couple days or this uh childcare center for a couple days
and just see how many people get walked in? Got a very obvious
front door.
Like that's all you would need to break this story basically
is all you would need to do is just stake out the front door
and count the people who go in. I understand that's not a that's
like a lot of work in the modern age of the internet. You just
stake out the [__] door and wait. Did they not do
that for any of these things? >> Can't open right now.
It's a weekday. >> Yeah, Rhox, I'm saying like you literally
just sit there. You go at 5:00 a.m. Sorry, 6 a.m. You go at 6
a.m. You wait for like 2 hours.
count how many people go in or come out. You go you go back at
uh I guess when work ends and then around 10 p.m. when they close
and see if people leave, right? >> And if this was a daycare
center, it wouldn't just be in some industrialized building.
There would be maybe like a playground or something outside or
>> there's no play area for the kids.
>> bro, how do how do daycarees work in the States? Because
from what I remember when I was a kid, all of my daycare places
were
like families. Families just ran a daycare in their house.
I I assume that's how it works everywhere for most
They went on Christmas Day. Are you guys sure they went on Christmas
Day?
Did they say they went on Christmas Day? This video is put out
on Boxing Day. I feel like I feel like this video was edited
together pretty heavily. Do we really believe they went on Christmas
Why are people saying they went on Christmas day? Mankind, you
just sound bunch of people saying, >> "Where are the kids?
Where's anybody? How can there be nobody here?" And it's like
this every single day. I've never seen a single child here in
nine years. I've never seen a single child at this building right
there. >> Okay.
Nine years. Has it been nine years? 2020. No, it's not. It's
not been nine years. >> Oh, then now looks like we already
got the Somali coming through. Yeah, they're coming. The word's
out. >> Hello. Is this your daycare? >> No. Can you
tell us why there are no children? Have you ever seen children
at this child care center? >> I should. I don't. >> Doesn't
know if she's ever seen a child here. All right, let's go to
the next location. And the fraud only gets more from here. Make
sure you stay till the very end of this video to see exactly
how much fraud we find by the time we are done. And before we
go to the next location, I want to show you something super interesting
about the flags of Minnesota. And here in Minnesota, if you take
a look at the Minnesota state flag,
>> oh god, they're going to it's like the Somali flag.
It's a takeover. >> They recently changed it and it very
much so resembles the flag of Somalia. And really quick, I want
to tell you guys about the sponsor of this video. how
and it very much [clears throat] >> so I call me crazy
but
wouldn't it be weird if the literal
Northstar state
didn't put a star on their flag it's I don't know a lot about
the US okay but I do know that Minnesota is called the North
Star state I
much so resembles the flag of Somalia and really Quick, I want
to tell you guys about the sponsor of this video, Opus Clip.
What used to just be an AI Clipper has back into the video. >> In
fiscal year 2025, 1,42,59
in fiscal year 2024 1,59,78.
And in fiscal year 2023, $727,336.
>> This next one is literally
one block away. in this. >> Now, one thing I wonder is
why is this not a individual tax return thing?
Does anyone know? I guess maybe because it's meant for low-inccome
people or something. I actually I I genuinely have no idea why
this wouldn't just because you get rid of the fraud if you just
let people reimburse themselves, right? But I guess if it's low-inccome
that that technically is like regressive. Those people might
not have the initial income to get child care for their kids,
right? One's also generated nearly $3 million in the past 3 years.
Let's see if there's any children. Let's see if any of the buildings
are open.
>> All right, we've arrived to ABC Learning
All the windows are blacked out. Let's see if anybody is here.
This door is >> This facility is licensed for 40
Zero children. I've come by this place a 100 times. I've never
seen a child here ever. The only thing I've ever seen is someone
standing outside smoking. >> What's crazy about this is
that last daycare center is that green building right there and
the other daycare center right now is right here. These buildings
should be operating as are receiving literally millions of dollars.
>> I knocked on the door and to my surprise, somebody actually
>> Wait,
I just realized I just realized. Do you think the reason all
of the windows are blocked out in all of like Minnesota is just
this one guy going around all the child care centers and like
peering in the windows?
There's some weird white guy, some weird old white guy shows
UP AND LOOKS AT ALL THE WINDOWS. I think it's possible, man.
>> He answered the door.
>> Can we speak?
>> I would like to check a child in the >> cops have
been looking for this weird keeps looking in all of these daycarees,
okay, for years. And now he's outed
>> Can I speak to a manager?
>> Where can I get paperwork to file for my son? I wanted
to put my son Joey in >> And after a few questions, the
lady went >> Looks like little Joey surely ain't. >> So,
the other thing about this that makes this look like lazy and
and and again, I'm racist. You want to convince me that minorities
are stealing money from me, although I'm a Canadian as well,
then I'm like I'm pretty aminable to that. Okay, you can convince
me that minorities are stealing money from me very easily. Okay,
but like if you actually wanted to do some kind of undercover
investigation here, why wouldn't you like not do it with GoPros?
Like you can clearly see he's got his camera. You could see it,
right? It's like why would you show up looking so sus? Why wouldn't
you be doing some like uh is it
Veraritoss? Why wouldn't you be doing like some Project Veraritoss
sting operation? Yeah. Yeah. Why wouldn't you be doing that?
Right. Like you're you're obviously like some random kid who's
[__] around. He's using his glasses
Okay. He's using his glasses camera. Okay. He didn't have his
phone out like
Maybe that's that's possible. That's possible. Hold on. That's
possible.
>> A child in the day. Can we speak? >> He is miked
up though, >> isn't it? >> I would like to check
a child. >> He is. He is. I believe he's miked up >> in
the dayare.
>> can I speak to a manager? >> No. Where can I get
paperwork to file for my son? I wanted to put my son Joey in
daycare. And after a few questions, the lady went silent. >> Looks
like little Joey surely ain't going to daycare here. >> And
now where are we going >> now? We're going to Sweet Angel
Child >> We're in the middle of a strip mall here inside
of this neighborhood. [snorts] >> In fiscal year 2025,
this facility, which says it's licensed for 74 kids, was paid
$1.26
million
in tax money. And there are no kids. And the all the facilities
are the same way. All of them. >> Let's see if anyone opens.
>> Yeah. Let's see. >> Once again, I try to find
a spot for my son Joey and they would not open the
>> I want to put my son Joey in. >> Okay. Now, this
one again, ring camera. And there's a guy with a big a big video
camera outside as well.
Right now, by the way, I think it's entirely possible that these
businesses could be fraudulent. I've seen no evidence that shows
that they're like kids at these businesses. Maybe they should
be investigated. Maybe this old guy saw something. Maybe this
is all weird. Maybe those vehicles really don't move. Maybe there's
a scam going on. But I don't want these people investigating
it. For one thing, they're obviously.
And I don't know why you could literally I
I actually do find it difficult to
I I really do genuinely that you wouldn't identify the idea that
a stakeout could prove this like like how long do you think you
got to tell this story? You've got you've got months to tell
this story. Like this was just getting reported. Like I think
I saw it pop back up maybe 6 months ago.
But this story is like a little bit old and you might have something
massive
Why wouldn't you go and stake these places out, right?
Like like why wouldn't you think, how do I get this rock solid?
How do I get this airtight so nobody can say I was wrong?
Right? Like there's so many holes in the way this story is presented
so far to me that I just don't understand why I I think almost
anybody even a zoomer cloutchasing racist would understand what
you need to make this airtight.
And I feel like they would do it. And I feel like when they I
man, in my heart of hearts, if I had to guess,
I think they probably did do it for one or two places and they
realized kids were showing up and then it made the whole thing
muddy. The local news reporters have been investigating this
since 2018.
Uh, the child care fraud, like actual childcare fraud, Black
Irish, cuz again, I'm saying I'm saying that you could almost
certainly prove the fraud here, right? You could I think you
could absolutely prove the fraud here because all it would take
from what I've seen when we saw the uh the news agency that said
they called around and saw like the government did do inspections
and stuff. All you'd need is a tip off from the government and
I do believe in in St. St. Paul but um
in Minneapolis there's there a lot of Somalian people there,
right? But yeah, if you've got more local reports, Black Irish,
I'm I'm totally down. I again I've not said this is wrong. I've
just noticed like issues with the way they're reporting this
so far and the way they're presenting the like there are plausibly
deniable things about a lot of this and I want
I feel like they'd have to understand that that hey if we show
up with like a big video camera you could see this guy with this
huge video camera shooting from the back that people might not
want to open up. This one goes over daycare fraud for the last
10 years. Okay, so it's going to go over daycare fraud. Let me
see. I is this gonna be relevant
or is this going to be like I hope this is relevant.
Threemonth investigation exposes daycare fraud in the mid
>> is this talking about the about this piece? What is
this YouTube video? Hold on. Is this talking about this piece?
>> It started with >> Hold on. I understand a ton
of people have been convicted of fraud in Minnesota, but I do
believe that's Is that food fraud? Is that like what it's like
a slightly different kind of fraud, isn't it? Or is it all childcare
fraud as well? Three-month investigation exposes daycare center
fraud in the millions. Oh,
hold on. Wait. This is from 2013.
>> For the Fox 9 investigators, and it led us to a story
that took three months of digging to uncover. >> Tonight,
Jeff Balian exposes a business that some of its own employees
say is misusing millions of taxpayers dollars. >> Let's
check this out. They made their move before the crack of dawn,
targeting child care centers in Minneapolis, St. Paul, and Apple
Valley, seizing computers and boxloads of documents as part of
a massive fraud investigation.
The raid included agents from the FBI, State Bureau of Criminal
Apprehension, and the Ramsey County Attorney's Fraud
It went down, coincidentally, as the Fox 9 investigators were
in the middle of our own probe of the same business. It's not
difficult to see a pattern of what's going on here. >> What
is going on? >> It's terrible how it's misused. >> We
spent 3 months >> digging through records, doing surveillance,
talking with >> Is this like female Stephen Hawking over
>> We spent three months digging through records, doing
surveillance, talking with insiders. >> It's big. It's
bigger than I think the state realizes >> to expose a scheme
that's costing tens of thousands of taxpayer dollars a week.
There's a live show, you know, if everything's fine with the
rules. >> Yasmin Ali is the owner of BCO Family Centers.
This is her giving a tour to
As a noticer, I'm noticing that this person is black and the
people doing it now are black. >> Producer, people that
work with >> tell our producer >> probably Somalian
looks.
It's the Corontos media arc. Okay. It's the Krontos media arc.
Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness.
[laughter] >> That many of our customers are on assistance.
They qualify to have the government pay for their kids childare.
They can get that help if they're working, training for a job,
or hunting for one. >> I think it's doing a disservice
to people that truly do need childare >> We interviewed
four Dico employees who have intimate knowledge of the operation.
They've also shared information with government fraud investigators.
Two agreed to talk on camera as long as we disguise them. >> So
they were misrepresenting a lot of what was going on there. >> Exactly.
According to our sources, Dico is actively recruiting women who
qualify for childcare assistance and offering them jobs at the
centers. Some to watch their own kids. In fact, these moms confirmed
to us. >> Hello. Uh do you work here? You do. How many
children do you have? >> Two. And the children come here
as well. >> Who pays for their childare? >> The town.
>> the county. >> The county. Do you then bills the
county for childare while the moms are supposedly working? >> Were
these legitimate jobs or not? >> No, there were too many
that were being hired. We didn't even need that many. >> Our
informants tell us that only a small percentage of the moms did
anything.
>> did some kind of work. >> Did some kind of work.
Sometimes they would come in, sign their children in, sign themselves
in, and go grocery >> Our sources say the more children
a woman had to enroll in childare, the >> Oh, see this
is so much more believable. This is so much more believable.
Immediately. be so much more believable >> make per hour
even though she had the same job title as all the other moms.
>> The reason for that is because then they had more assistance
for each of the >> On numerous occasions we saw lots of
women coming to the centers each with four, five or more kids
in tow. >> Her value was in how many children she >> This
lady is white. They let one white lady in and she ratted on the
whole operation.
Can't give white people nothing. Okay, they don't appreciate
>> According to government records, Deco's Minneapolis
and St. Paul centers were each eligible to receive nearly $50,000
in childare assistance funds every 2 weeks. Do the math. That's
over 2 million a year. >> They're making a ton of money.
According to our insiders, time sheets were submitted to the
county which inflated the hours the moms actually spent in the
centers allowing to build the government for max. >> See,
this is how you do fraud, right? This is how you actually do
fraud is you need names. You need identities on paper. This is
how like when they're like, "Oh, there are no kids at any of
these childcare centers." I'm like, "Dude, really?
Maybe maybe you could believe that they started doing it during
CO and then they just kept doing it or something."
>> Maximum childare time. >> So, they fixed the time
schedule. >> A lot of women they did this for. >> Yes.
State inspection reports obtained by the Fox 9 investigators
show Dico has previously been cited for a number of logistical
problems, including a lack of keeping accurate records of when
staff works. They were also fined for failing to do background
checks on employees and ordered to provide documented proof that
staff members received mandated safety >> While employed
there, I saw falsifying
>> So, the record show they received this training, but
in fact, they had not. >> I stopped by Dico's Apple Valley
office to speak with owner Yasmin Ali. She wouldn't go on camera,
but I did record our conversation. >> We're told that you
were falsifying records to get childare money. >> That's
not true, but I, as I say, I'm not going to have any comments
right >> In addition to all the funds for childare, do
was also getting public money for kids meals. The Minneapolis
Center got nearly $90,000 for food in his first year of operation.
This place did the catering. It's owned by Yasmin Ali's brothers.
>> See, this is this is so much more compelling is fraud
because this is exactly how I'd expect it to work. Like some
insulated group of businesses they build up to go and do this
cuz they're like, "Oh, we can figure out how to get like our
kids childcare paid for." And it's not like like kids are getting
taken care of, kids are getting fed, but they're also they're
running like a
Um, the idea that they're just running these totally empty childcare
centers, that seems far less believable to me. >> In daycare,
>> cuz I need a spot to put my son Joey. >> Yes.
What's up? >> Is this your daycare center? >> No,
I want to work there. What's happen? >> Well, I just want
to put a chop. >> Wait.
Um, you see this? It's from It's in NY post, so probably legit.
It's from a place Nick went to apparently. Oh, please tell me
that they are they moving the bodies. Don't move the bodies,
man.
Shocking unearthed footage shows a parent parents pretending
to drop kids off at a Minnesota daycare center. Shocking foot
unearthed video from a 2018 state fraud case shows Minnesota
parents dropping their children off.
Uh Minnesota parents dropping their children off. Uh
oh. At a daycare center. Jesus, I just lost my place in the page
somehow. Scrolled and lost it entirely. Off at a daycare center
and then leaving with the kids moments later as authorities probe
a rampant billion dollar fraud scheme in Minneapolis. In surveillance
in the surveillance footage dated 2015 and obtained by Fox 9,
parents see are seen signing their kids into the facility so
providers could build the state for full days of care for children
who didn't actually attend. On some days, no families would even
show up at all. But the daycarees would still claim reimbursements
from the government and the outlet reported at the time. Ooh,
what is this?
In order for the scene to work, daycare centers need to sign
up lowincome families that qualify for child care assistance
funding. >> These surveillance videos are from a case prosecuted
by Henipin County. They show parents checking their kids into
a
>> Oh, is this just from the same video? >> Hold
on. It's from this video, isn't it? >> Contract signed
by Adus Ali. We've seen his signature before on federal court
documents in 2009 guilty to perjury. The >> It's like the
same voice though, isn't it? and jury testified he knew nothing
about Somali men only to leave with them a few minutes later.
>> Yeah, it's Fox 9 as well. >> No children would
show up. But either way, the center would bill the state for
a full day of child care. This video from that same case shows
a man handing out envelopes of what are believed to be kickback
payments to parents who are in on the fraud. >> Where was
the money going? I don't know exactly where it went, but it
So, it seems like there have been child care schemes in Minnesota
from Somalian people before. Like, here's the thing. What I'm
trying not to do is I do believe that
there's probably something weird going on here. Okay. It seems
like the Somalian community in Minnesota, and I hate to paint
them with a broad brush, we're doing some fraud. And they probably
would have known about some fraud. and and immigrant communities,
especially first generation, second generation immigrant communities,
are really tightly knit, right?
They're really tightly knit. So, I think if they were coming
up with like some kind of racket that they would kind of transmit
that out through the community and they might be able to keep
it under wraps.
I believe that. I need to see the evidence. Right. This documentary
I I believe almost certainly is painting too broad a brush, right?
Way too broad a brush. There's not much evidence. Wait, there's
two different investigations apparently over a decade of time
where this community specifically is doing childcare fraud,
right? We're seeing two different investigations, two different
reports from Fox 9. One from 2013, 12 years ago, where this community
specifically is doing this kind of fraud. And now we're seeing
like, oh, it's a Somalian man handing money off to a Somalian
woman or a African Muslim immigrants maybe.
Right? This is far more compelling than the Nick video to me.
Like they're picking this stuff up from the state government.
They're not like running their own Well, they said they were
running their own investigation, but it's the state government
looking into this stuff for fraud. An envelope that they assume
was a kickback payment. Well, hold on. Is he saying they assume?
When he says they assume, is he just reading? This is a local
station. Uh, this is a local station. I don't think you should
be treating this with the level of concern you are. >> Sometimes
man handing out care. This video from that same case shows a
man handing out envelopes of what are believed to be kickback
payments to
So this they're talking about the investigators into this case,
right? Believe these to be kickback payments. So hold on. When
is this from 2018? So this is 2018 versus the 2013 case that
we're looking back looking at here. What are believed to be?
Yeah. Like they're not even being like crazy with the language.
They're clearly referencing a case that was prosecuted. What
are believed to be Okay, I'm telling you that everything about
this seems like solid journalism to me. It seems to be solid
journalism.
It's from 2013 before things got insane.
And they're saying there were state investigations into this.
Such an easy Okay, hold on. Uh, let me fire up Perplexity or
something. I'll I'll do this in the background while we watch
a little bit more of the Nick Shirley thing. The Nick Shirley
thing is like a mislead that they might get like totally they
might be totally
stepping into something that could be real. Okay. Now, I haven't
seen evidence of $9 billion in fraud happening in Minnesota or
some crazy amount of fraud happening in Minnesota. Okay. But
I've seen that there is a lot of evidence that this specific
community was fraudulently pursuing childare and now we've got
a whole bunch of like industrial
area buildings that are supposedly running childare with the
same community. I'm like, "Oh,
and this guy is saying he notices a pattern." Now, we'll watch
the rest of the video,
but I'm not going to immediately go and just say, "Well,
that doesn't mean anything. This guy this old guy's crazy and
racist." I'm going to I'm going to look at the facts as they
come up, but I'll look at the I'll look for the other two investigations
as I watch this video. >> But all the daycare centers be
seem to be closed.
>> No one's opening the doors. >> You work here?
>> I was. Yeah. What's happening? >> Where are the
kids?
>> It says it's licensed for 74 children
right here. State of Minnesota. Where are the kids? They got
paid $1.26 million in fiscal year 2025. It says that to have
a capacity for 74 children.
>> When when >> Where are the kids? right here. State
of Minnesota website. You work here and you don't know. >> I
don't know. I was there before. I don't know what's going on.
>> Were there any kids when you worked >> He's there.
Kids there. What's >> How many? >> I don't know.
I don't. >> You don't know? >> You worked here? Okay.
Well, then you're not of any help. >> Can I put my son
in a >> Bro, why is he being so aggressive? You could get
good
again. These people suck, man. Why are you being so aggro on
this guy? This guy was actually talking to you. That should be
like gold
being so insanely
racist.
Well, I don't know about racist, but dude, you're just you're
not trying to find something out >> in a daycare here.
>> No, no, no, I don't know. >> Can I speak to someone?
>> No, I don't know. >> No. Yeah. I would like to
see if I can put my son Joey here. >> Who's your son Joey?
>> My son Joey? Can I check out daycare
>> Okay. We've got a report here produced by the state
government. Childcare Assistance Program Assessment of Fraud
Allegations. Okay. From 2019. Okay. Okay. Okay. Well, do you
put your kid here in the daycare?
>> There is one child in there. Yeah. I would like to know
if this is a legit >> Me? I'm scared of you, too. How come
I explain everything? >> You're scared of me? >> Yeah.
Because of your curry.
>> Because of my color. You said you're scared of me because
of my color. Does that make you a racist? [laughter] >> White
devil. White devil. >> No. You said you're you said you're
scared of me because of my color. >> I'm not saying you're
racist. >> You you said you're scared of me because of
my color. That makes you a racist. >> So right now they're
all getting mad cuz he's showing the paperwork of this business
being registered as a business. 74 children, no children. We
saw one child when the lady opened up the door.
>> So now they're all getting mad. What was this money
spent on?
>> 1.26 million. What was that money spent? >> There
aren't any kids. >> Ask the owner. On the kids. Well, then
why are you talking for the owner if you're telling me to talk
to THE OWNER? >> I'M SORRY. >> I'M NOT UNDERSTAND
what you're talking >> Do you have a child here?
>> Does anybody?
>> Where are the 74 kids? Did you lose them? Did you lose
these kids? Do I need to call someone? Do I need to issue an
Amber Alert for missing children?
>> Are these children missing?
>> It's not my business that children are missing. 74 infants
and TODDLERS
THE PROOF'S RIGHT THERE. There's no children anywhere >> from
the state of Minnesota. Right here,
>> dude. Did Atriarch really call this good reporting?
There's the Atriarch. I I genuinely have seen some Atriarch content
and I'm like, "Oh, I got a lot of respect for this guy. He went
from gooning to like deep fake nudes of his friends to doing
like real political work. That's that's cool, man. I got like
a lot of respect for the guy. Did he really say this is like
amazing
It's not. It's actually like really awful journalism.
>> We're moving on to the next location.
>> Have a good day. >> As we continue to show the
blatant fraud that was taking place here in Minnesota. Somali
started following us around the >> And now we're being
followed by the Somali. This is another daycare center. Absolutely
no signage and there's no footprints in the snow of children
playing outside.
$5 million within the past >> 59 million in two years.
5.9 million they received. >> They're trying to track kids
like >> in two years. That facility right there. >> And
now we have a group of Somali
>> Check what Atriox said in just the first couple of minutes.
>> Oh, come on, man.
Please. >> This is a spicy one today. This is a this is
a big topic. I I have a lot >> I already hate music. So
bear >> this is like the Wii music, right? >> To
catch you up. There is a massive fraud scandal unfolding in Minnesota
right now. Primarily on the Somali community of Minnesota dealing
with millions, if not billions of dollars of taxpayer money funneled
into things like luxury vacations, luxury cars, and massive stacks
of cashes overseas. Now, I want to give credit here. Uh the person
who really blew this story up on social media and YouTube is
this young guy, Nick Shirley. Here's him right now at one example
we'll talk about, which is a so-called learning center in uh
in Minnesota that was billing the government to do learning for
kids. >> Here in Minnesota, massive fraud is taking place
within the government and the Somali population. Here, this building
alone, quality learning center is a daycare. Yet, they spelled
learning wrong and they said learning. This daycare alone in
2025 has received $ 1.9 million from the government. the
>> Hold on. Hold on. I I had something for this. I had
something for this. I had something for this. Hold on. Sorry.
Uh you wait. Hold on. Atriarch. Atro. Here we are. >> Childare
centers is >> If those kids existed, they would be very
upset. >> No one here right now. It's midday on a weekday.
If you were trying to go inside, it's completely closed and the
windows are all blacked out. >> Not a great look. Not a
great look. In the video, he goes around with this. It's actually
a pretty insane tag team of like a seemingly cloud goblin zoomer
and like this old guy David here who's like all the files and
paperwork from 10 years of tracking this and their combination
is actually kind of beautiful. They go around and investigate
all these different buildings. They're supposedly, you know,
offering learning the kids or food or >> Oh, I will also
say that while this guy seemed racist at first, the presence
of like widescale fraud within this specific community and a
report being produced for fraud in that specific community, that
makes it seem a little less racist. It's more like he if he was
aware of it, which I assume he is, then that seems more like
he was like, "Oh, not sure that they given up this whole racket
or that people looked into it harshly enough." seems more along
those lines. Okay. So, slight slight
removal of debuff >> for autism preparedness and uh there's
no kids and they're all charging government large amounts of
money. So, I respect a lot the work of this this dude on the
rac. There's parts of the video I don't like like when they have
AI generated sora videos of black people throwing money in the
air and luxury cars. I think it sends the wrong message, but
the core journalism of actually going to investigate was was
great and I really enjoyed it. So listen, let let's back up here.
When it comes to government fraud, there's a general zoomed out
pattern. You should take a look. We watch. This is what everybody
votes on and follows up on and takes interest in. And then this
orange
>> Oh, people do people do like to say that like oversight's
not that important. >> Don't really care about it. They're
too busy campaigning for the next thing. Uh the news doesn't
really follow up on it. We don't really know. And so the actual
like how does this get done and where does this money go is very
nebulous and vague often. And this is a >> well that's
that's why you should you should be thinking about this like
what I said was if you were paying if you were reimbursing
individual parents for child care I think that looks a lot better
while while that is possibly like open to fraud at the individual
level in the same way then you get to go and like confirm that
the businesses then you get to do like check checking the books
right you check the books back and forth
like the businesses would have to file taxes too and you could
just do an audit of that and then it's like pretty obvious here.
You're just paying all these centers and then well I guess I
guess you ask for you do it inversely, right? You'd ask for the
parents. You need a way to double check the customers and
the individual like
business runners
and make sure that people are actually paying out for the stuff
that's being paid into the business. Although I guess if they
were doing kickbacks that could be the case and you wouldn't
really be able to track it that well. >> Ripe area, ripe
arbitrage area for fraud. Okay, this orange area because this
gap between big pile of money and thing that needs to get done
could be filled with friends of the politician. It could be filled
with people that aren't that good at teaching kids how to ride
bikes, a big sign, and then they get a check from the government
and and that's that. And so these empty restaurants start pulling
in huge amounts of money, millions of dollars in child food aid.
This one, this one example safari restaurant claimed to serve
3,500 meals in a day, yet looked relatively empty. Another restaurant
claimed 6,000 in a day in a town of 20.
Wait,
is the reason the Somali are getting caught is because they
stuck at understanding how much money they should say they should
get? Is that why they is that why they're getting caught? All
the white people doing this fraud, they're like, "Listen, we're
going to take 10% on top of our regular business." And all the
Somalians are like, "2600 people? Yeah, we we served a million
dollars in meals this year.
It's like,
what are you doing? You're not feeding the whole town.
Hey, you could do this. You did this the same way the white people
are. They're taking like 10% off the top, but you're you're going
to sit here
and just totally defraud the government, not even make the meals.
What are you doing, man? >> 600 people. So, you might be
wondering, if these empty looking restaurants are charging for
huge amounts of children, wouldn't somebody go check? Wouldn't
somebody show up at the door unannounced and just make sure there's
actually people there that they claim to be before they send
the check? Normally, they did do that, but in CO because of >> Okay,
so they didn't do this during CO. That's fine. That's fine. Does
he reference this 2019
thing
or is it mostly very common? Okay. All right. Oh man. Okay, this
is a bad look. Okay, this is a bad look for immigrant communities.
If some of this comes out to be true, even if they, by the way,
even if Nick Shirley has sensationalized this like 10x,
it's still going to look really bad on the immigrant communities
in Minnesota if they're doing mass amounts of fraud. Okay? But
by participating in like an insular
sort of like what would you call it? like a like an any insulated
community of immigrants. It's going to look really really really
really really really really bad. Especially when they already
got caught in 2019 doing this exact thing. Okay. Well, I guess
we have to look through this 64 pages. We will start reading
this very soon in our vehicle right now. >> From this daycare
center, we headed over to the infamous Quality Learning Center,
>> Okay, hold on. I didn't get to that part. You're right.
I do want to hear the part where Atriox says he respects these
people. One second. This is a spicy one. >> One second.
One second. One second. One second. Respect >> large amount
of money. So, I respect a lot the work of this this duo and what
they did. There's >> Did you Did say that
>> parts of the video I don't like like when they have
AI generating. >> Parts of the video I don't like. Yeah.
I Dude, people are kind of on autopilot when they watch stuff.
What can you do? What can you do? People are just on autopilot
when they watch stuff. I was on autopilot when I was watching
Atriarch. Didn't catch him say he respects these people.
Ah, not this one. >> Actually actual learing center on
the outside of their sign. That's how blatant this fraud is here
at this >> Don't open up. >> So this is quality
learing center. I meant to say quality learning center. >> Don't
open up. >> They said they spelled >> Why is somebody
yelling don't open up?
>> Don't open up. >> How do you have ice here, ma'am?
I'm literally a YouTuber. >> Don't open up. Ma'am, what
do you think about the fraud that's taking place here in M? >> Oh
god, it's the it's the woman who gangstaled Legal Mindset. It's
It's literally the woman who gangstaled Legal Mindset. She's
here. She's following all these people. Okay, >> Don't
open up. We have ice. >> And what do you think about this
place being licensed for 99 children? >> Don't open up
>> and getting $4 million over the >> Don't open
up. It's ice. >> $4 million in the last two years. >> Go
away. >> What do you think about that? Are you in favor?
Are you in favor of that? >> Go away. You're not welcome
here. Shame on you. >> Are you in favor of
>> $1.9 million going illegally? >> Don't open up
>> fraudulently to this business that has quality learning
center but can't even spell learning right on the door. >> Don't
open up
again. They got a phone number up there. Why don't you just start
calling the phone number being like, "Hey, I'm looking for uh
like a daycare in Minnesota, and this is really close to where
I work, and it would be really super helpful if I could like
drop my kid off here." Right? >> We are not ICE. >> I
don't care who you are. You don't belong here. >> I belong
here just like you belong here. >> Don't open up. It's
ice. >> You do realize that there's supposed to be 99 children
here. >> I actually love her. Wait, what do you love about
this?
I swear. Don't. Uh, dude, the communist thing that happens, this
is like a lefty thing that happens. Oh, it's so cool to like
flout authority in any case. No, it's not.
You're not a revolutionary. It's not cool to just like, oh, if
it's if it's the cops, oh, don't open up. It's the cops. You're
a If you think that anything that that offic Sorry, like um obstructs
like any government authority at all. Anything that's not always
good.
What if I am one? Okay. Well, you are. You are. If you're just
saying in this household that woman is a hero, I Okay, if it
was Okay, if it was literally ice, yes. If it was literally Ice,
I agree. Okay, but it's not Ice. It's a YouTuber. If she was
just saying If she was just saying, "Don't open up. There's some
fslur out here." Then she would be awesome. Okay, [laughter]
that would be cool. But she's yelling ice and then she's not
even Why doesn't she talk to them if she's recording them?
I I hate people who are like obstinate like this. It's It's very
annoying to me when people are like this.
That's just me personally.
>> Add this. >> YouTubers are worse than ICE. >> The
building, but there's no one here.
>> This is a child daycare center. >> 99 children
paid $1.9 million this year in CCAP funding. Do you know where
the children are? Were they kidnapped? They run away.
Where are the children? This is state of Minnesota
right here. >> And who are you? >> My name is Nick
Shirley, ma'am. >> And who are you with? >> Nick
Shirley. Nick Shirley on YouTube. >> Yeah. So, who are
you with here? >> Oh, he's just been doing some research,
investigating the fraud that's taking place here in Minnesota.
>> Yeah, I'm with Nick Shirley. >> This lady, she's
calling us ICE. We're just trying to put law and order back in
>> um he could probably get told to stay off the property.
Evil Johnny Bravo. Do you think he'd get in trouble for leading
your kids? No. I mean, technically, he says he never saw a kid,
so obviously not. >> Streets of the United States.
>> Get rid of all the fraud. Have you ever seen children
at that daycare center right there? >> Yeah, it's right
there. It says the child. You've never seen
>> We're gonna educate you on something. So, what do you
think about this daycare center? They spelled learning wrong.
They've received over $1.9 million this year alone, and they're
supposed to have 99 children here. >> I don't see it. >> Hold
on. Wait. Is it actually It's not New Year's Eve, guys. It's
It's literally the 30th of December. The 31st of December is
tomorrow. >> It's not New Year's Eve. >> Seen any
children here? >> None. Not at all.
>> Last This year they got 1.9 million. Last year they
got 1.5 million of your tax money for 99 children. We just want
to know where are the kids,
>> Where are the children? >> I don't see them. >> I
will say I will say again I'm not necessarily like an investigator.
Okay.
But I've seen a pattern here.
This video is released on December 26th actually. But um
I've noticed a pattern here that when you have these daycare
centers, they're also set up with restaurants nearby that are
owned by similar people to who own the restaurant or sorry the
the daycare center. So I'm wondering if you could do business
records in Minnesota for Albi Restaurant. I'm wondering if this
restaurant where they happen to also have the daycare center.
Did we do any looking into this like in the most obvious way
where we could go look up the business records for this place
and see if it matches the name or is a similar name, similar
last name, same last name maybe to the people who own the daycare
center,
then you're cooking with gas. Why wouldn't you go use the same
pattern that was used in 2019?
The last one place was debunked kind of. Okay. How payments,
the exception, one that closed years ago and the misspelled quality
learning center, which Brown says permanently closed last week.
In a strange contradiction,
however, our cameras this afternoon captured dozens of children
being dropped off at that daycare. The manager telling us they
are legitimate. They are
this you're saying this is debunking? Is this really debunking
or did somebody say, "Well, the business has been closed actually
closed permanently last week." Actually, never mind. We're gonna
have a whole bunch of kids coming in here.
>> Yeah. Who said that it closed last week? Hold on.
>> Here at this building, but there's no one here. >> While
we have questions about some of the methods that uh were used
in the video, we do take the concerns that the video raises about
fraud very seriously. >> Responsible for paying federal
child care assistance to daycarees that file claims. She says
inspectors went out today to doublech checkck that children in
fact are present. The federal department of homeland security
also was checking those businesses in Minneapolis today. State
data Shirley used in his video show those daycarees receive millions
in taxpayer money. >> There have been ongoing investigations
with um se several of those centers. None of those investigations
uncovered findings of fraud. >> Brown confirmed that the
daycarees in Shirley's video have active licenses with the state
and continue receiving payments. the exception, one that closed
years ago and the misspelled Quality Learning Center, which Brown
says permanently closed last week. >> Okay,
does that not seem super weird that it permanently closed last
week? The government official is saying it permanently closed
last week. I believe Brown is this woman who I believe is somebody
from the government. We take fraud very seriously. Who is she
specifically? Let's see if it says in the thing here. It does
not. Who Who's she? Just one stop. conservative YouTuber Nick
Shirley made in a video viewed over 100 million times on X. Tiki
Brown is the commissioner of the new Minnesota Department of
Children, Youth, and Families, which is respon
so Tiki Brown
confirmed
that this is the case. Hickeyi Brown. Uh
um that
are there not like a billion new questions
immediately when she says this place had its license. This place
closed permanently last week and then a bunch of families show
up bringing like boatloads of kids in. I that is bizarre to me
because here's the thing. I I straight up don't believe that
if these businesses were fraudulent that they could succeed on
their own. I do believe that that would be a very large conspiracy
that probably requires like some kind of heads up from the government.
I'm telling you. I mean, it was probably still open without a
license. Nick got there before it opened. He got to this one
before it opened.
Okay. So, how do we contend with the fact that the paperwork
for this place says it says it's like a day daycare center and
then there apparently they had a sign up that says 2 p.m. is
when they open. How do we contend with that, Kger? that this
place is supposed to be for like day shift, people who work like
during the day, but it opens at 2 p.m. Yeah. I don't know. I
just I what I wouldn't want to do here is sully my own credibility
by trying to go, "Oh, no, we have to assume these are all operating
like really well when it seems like there's a pattern in Minnesota
of this kind of fraud happening with this community specifically."
And then I I like unreasonably push back against everything trying
to find any way to make this not true. I think that's probably
not how I'd want to approach this. I do think this Nick this
Nick Shirley guy is like a he seems like a
but it there might be something actually going on here.
So, I'm going to I'm going to keep looking. And I I do think
this one's kind of a there's a lot of weird going on already
with this specific daycare center that has the misspelled thing.
Was it inside? Was it better? Hold on. Inside. Did they have
the right name? Nope.
Learning Center. Quality Learning Center, which Brown says permanently
closed last week.
>> They also interviewed the son of this specific place.
Okay, hold on. >> Will be fixed by this week. >> It'll
be fixed by this week. >> Has it been this way for the
past eight and a half years that you've been open? Do you know?
>> No. No. We paid someone. We paid a graphic designer.
Clearly didn't do a good job. We try to get back. >> Okay.
Are we
airline? This is the I'm not This is
>> We try to get back to him. I don't want to mention his
name in his business for a while now. For like 3, four months.
I'm out of the country. I'm not here. I'll get it fixed. But
by the end of this week, it'll be fixed. >> The street
is also misspelled. >> Do you notice that? >> The
street is also misspelled, isn't it? >> Both of those will
be fixed by the end of the week. >> Both of those, but
just a rhetoric that there's fraud going on. >> You guys
can feel free to come. You guys can come tomorrow.
>> Does is this compelling to people? I every statement
I've got from somebody trying to debunk this has made me like
has made it seem more suspicious to me. I'm It's easy to debunk.
It would be very easy to debunk. Right. >> Mondays through
Thursdays though. We're not open Fridays. It's not Friday. We're
not open Saturdays. We're not open Sunday. You guys can feel
feel free to
>> Don't plan on closing anytime soon. >> Can you
tell us your name again one more >> AI. Last name I
>> B R A. Appreciate you guys. >> What's your title?
>> We'll be fixed by this. I
I Okay, something sus is going on. I feel like something sus
is going on and it's not because of this guy's documentary. It's
because of other stuff and [snorts]
literally just the way people are trying to debunk this stuff.
It It makes no sense to me. Okay, so somebody mentioned somewhere
I've seen this that this place is registered as like a day daycare
center. Can we find How would I find this business? How would
I go try to find these documents for myself? Hold on. I need
to figure this out in the background. Um, how can I find business
documents for child care centers in
Cuz if I have to do some kind of request, I'm probably not doing
that. I'm probably not going to that level. Didn't Veto do some
digging? Maybe he did. I do remember Veto asking why
what kind of childcare center opens at 2 p.m. and closes at 10.
Hold on. Veto comedy.
What has Veto been saying?
Veto is a base racist. Okay, we love
Officials have been investigating for years, yet all these shady
businesses remain open. Sounds like a motivated journalist just
kicked the system in the
This might be my read at the end of all of this. Hold on. Oh,
I saw this with the HHS. That's also not good. I don't think
this is good.
They go, we're feeding We're freezing all federal taxpayer money
here before you figure out what's going on. I don't think that's
smart. That seems pretty.
Where are we going? Where can we Dude,
okay, dude. Veto tweets too much. He's not a big He's not a big
fan of the crassenstein. This veto guy, you attempted to buy
the domain name
in 2007. Maybe you shouldn't be the one accusing others of behavior.
I was just buying domain names as a business opportunity. Teampie.com.
Teampies.com.
Damn. Atriox video on this was pretty good. Wait, was it? cuz
we just watched some of Atriarch's video and he liked the journalism
of these guys. The journalism of these guys sucks.
These guys have already made like multiple errors. They could
have easily just validated this, produced something very very
high quality that would have put this guy's name on the map.
Instead, they just did some shoddy work that he's basically just
like thrown lawn darts at a at what could be a big story. >> Been
here since 2017. I haven't seen anybody like that. Never seen
a child >> Not at all. >> And so you've never seen
a child here for eight years? >> Nope. Not at all.
And how does [snorts] that make you feel knowing that this place
is receiving $1.9 million? >> Disgusting. [sighs] I mean,
what the hell? They stealing the money. That's a federal grant,
too. That's if they get caught for that's a federal offense.
>> I don't know. I said he'd lie. >> And do you think
Tim Waltz should
go to jail for all the fraud? That's he
>> cool. Enabled here in his state. >> That's him
doing this.
Heck yeah.
>> Ask this guy. Ask this guy
why wars in the Middle East happen. Okay. I need that as a test
question. I need that as a test question. I I feel like this
guy's going to have a lot of opinions on a lot of things. >> He's
got to be helicopter with us. I mean, there's no there's no rhyme
or reason what's going on here. It's simple. It's nothing there.
It's a parking lot. >> And look, they even spelled learning
wrong on their sign for a place that's supposed to be educating
children.
>> That's crazy.
I mean, who who runs it? Who supposedly runs it?
>> Oh my god. [laughter] Oh, where? Where? Yeah, it's just
I've never seen nobody here at all. >> So, how long you
been living here? >> Since 2017.
>> Never seen a single child walk in that >> No,
not at all. >> So, this big daycare center is literally
just a place to traffic, money. $1.9 million just this year alone.
And this guy's been living here for eight years. Has never seen
a single child walk through those doors. There's no windows either.
No. >> And the only window they do have, the door is blacked
out. >> Yep. I see that.
I've never seen anybody go in there. >> Within just a few
hours, we nearly approached $20 million in fraud. And we headed
over to George Floyd's neighborhood to expose more of the fraud
taking place. >> This place is called Future Leaders Early
Learning Center and it's licensed for 90 children. And in fiscal
year 2025,
they received 3.6.
>> Oh, did we did anybody do this? Hold on.
Did anybody do this? Is this where it used to be? Or is this
where it still is? Cuz this kind of looks like the front of that
Aldi restaurant or whatever, right?
Well, let me go Let me go back here. Is that the front of this
restaurant? This Albi place? It looks like the Am I
Right. If we look this up on maps,
is it the Is it this Albi restaurant? Hold on. Albi Kitchen is
at Yes, it is this Albi restaurant. Now, now this Albi Kitchen,
it's this front storefront is like where this was.
Don't see Albi on the sign though. Yeah, but the Albi kitchen
is what goes right here. And then if you go back over here,
then this is where the quality learning center thing would be
is over right here. There's like this door and it was like a
sign over here. Oh, wait. Is this right? This is 1413. Yeah,
this is the front of the building and this is where the new place
is. Oh, no, no, no, Ry. I'm not looking at that place. I'm looking
at quality. This is quality learning center, which they had it
set up correctly before in 2022. So, it hasn't been that long
the sign's been broken for. Okay. The next building. What do
you mean it's the next building?
How could it be the next building? This building is like way
different. I'm telling you, this this is where the restaurant
is right now. Cuz I literally looked up the restaurant. The restaurant
is literally right there.
Look, the restaurant's literally there. Albi Kitchen and it's
like right here. Literally see outside. When you look at Albi
Kitchen and you go see outside, it literally has the childcare
center thing right there. And so there's some door here where
they that they've put in that they can go here. That's not the
building in the video. The walls a different color. Then the
WALL GOT PAINTED CUZ IT'S THE SAME GODDAMN ADDRESS. I'M TELLING
YOU, the same goddamn address. There's like music box here. Hold
on. Let's see if that's up the street or something. Music box
RIGHT THERE. SAME GODDAMN BUILDING.
Don't tell me what I'm talking about. You don't do these investigations
for a living. Okay,
working my fingers to the bone out here. Now, what I want to
do is search business filings
by business name. Albi
Kitchen. Can I Does this show up? Albi. Can I just search Albi?
Albi. Albi. Albi. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm
looking. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking. I should look
to see if I can find by address here. Can I find this by address?
I can't. I have to search business name. Okay. Well, I'm going
to get back you guys back to the video here. I'm just trying
to find basically like the business license for this place so
that I can try
to see who owns it. You surely claimed there were no windows,
but the windows are on the front. Okay, but the windows are into
the kitchen. And if you looked at the Google list, you're trying
really hard for rain.
The windows are on the front. Yeah, the windows are on the front,
but this is the kitchen right now. When they went here, this
is the kitchen.
We get that, right? that this is the kitchen
and the side door was like for the learning center. I'll be as
a legit business at least. Yeah, maybe. Okay, hold on. We'll
>> at none. I don't see him. I've been here >> out
here for 9 minutes.
>> Tim Waltz should go to jail for all the fraud that he's
enabled here in his >> That's him doing this. Heck yeah.
He's got to be held accountable for this. I mean, there's no
there's no rhyme or reason what's going on here. It's simple.
It's nothing there. parking lot >> look at the Google pics.
No, I know Albi Kitchen is a business. I know. >> They
spelled learning wrong on their sign for a place that's supposed
to be educating children children.
That's crazy. I mean, who who runs it? Who supposedly runs it?
>> Somalians. Oh my god.
Oh my god. [laughter] But what where? Yeah, it's just I've never
seen nobody here at all. >> So, how long you been living
here? since
>> Never seen a single child walk in that >> No,
not at all. >> So this big
>> h the all kitchen website.
H
where would this person be from?
Where would this person be from? H
>> daycare center is literally just a place to traffic
money. $1.9 million just this year alone. And this guy's been
living here for 8 years and has never seen a single child walk
through those doors. There's no windows either. >> And
the only window they do have, the door is blacked out. >> Yep,
I see that.
I've never seen anybody go in there. >> Within just a few
hours, we nearly approached $20 million in fraud.
>> My question would be if they've got a door for it and
they've got like
would they really have room? Where would they have room for kids
in there that they're running a whole restaurant?
Where would there be room?
The people that own that kitchen are committing fraud. I mean,
where are the kids going?
How many how many kids were they licensed for? Did they say how
many kids this place was licensed for?
The quality learning center. Quality Learing Center. This is
what 1633. Let me go check the transcript here.
This one is licensed for licensed
that's 99 kids quality learning center. >> I will be licensed
for 99 children. Reban Rubin donated $3. If only there was a
musical cue that would let us know where you thought that person
was from. >> Wait, is there a musical cue for this? There
isn't for There isn't.
What's the musical cue for Somalian pirates? I don't even know
what that it would be. Yeah. So, 1.9 million in funding in 2025.
And this place is in the back of a shoe box. This one, I feel
like this one's quite difficult to believe. I find it a little
difficult to believe. Okay, so license for 99 that doesn't necessarily
mean 99, but 2 million in funding for that year is pretty high,
right? Like we we don't know what else is in this building. This
one looks like clear fraud to me. And then I got Vain sitting
over here going like, "Look, the kid came out the the child of
the the business owners came out and said that like, oh, it's
not fraudulent at all. There's no fraud going on."
What? CCAP? No. CCAP program Minnesota.
is the childcare assistance program in Minnesota is CCAP
fiscal year 2025 CCAP funding $1.9 million. So I what I think
happened here. Okay. No, no, no. It's not 1.9. They're they're
funding that's not the approval. It says fiscal year they were
funded for 1 Well, maybe it is saying they're funded for 1.9
million. Maybe they're misreading this whole thing. If they're
misreading this whole thing, then they're Look at how big the
Oh, sure. Hold on. Um, go back to the map view. No, no. Let me
go back to the map view. Why can I never go back to the map view?
Hold on. Me go back to the map view, please. Thank you.
So, we zoom in on this place. How big is the building?
I mean, it's not that big a building, dog. It's not that BIG
A BUILDING, DOG. What the are they doing, bro? License for 99
kids. Like, shouldertosh
What's out back? Oh, it looks like there is a thing for kids
out back. Now, this was like a kid center. This is a This looks
like a swing set or something. Hold on. Can we drop down back
there or can we drop down? We can drop down right here. Is that
it? Across. That is it. You look over in here. There's like this
fenced off area back here. I think this one could have been a
childare center. And I'm not sure that that's what this one is
anymore. No, no, no. 99's got to be capacity. License for is
capacity. That's your capacity. They they've licensed you for
up to 99 kids. I'm guessing they put a kitchen in and they never
announced to the government that they were going to be putting
that kitchen in. Now there is a possibility here where this is
like the how much funding they are allocated as in like this
is how much funding you could apply for based on there's a small
chance I don't think it' be listed this way that then this would
be this guy fundamentally misunderstanding his documents right
licensing lookup DHS DHS state Minnesota okay hold on let's take
a look let's take a look let's take a
quality learning center. Okay, we're looking at the details here.
Okay, this is already looking weird. It's already looking weird,
guys. So, they had a licensing review on June 23rd of 2025.
See violations
day program infants, toddlers, preschool, school age facility
areas used by children were not in good repair. infants and toddler
care. Crib mattresses or sheets did not meet safety requirements
and/or items were in a crib for an infant under 12 months. Okay.
Um written parental permission adoption obtained for administering
medicine or topical products. The program did not follow healthcare
provers written instructions when administering prescription
medication postings. A licensing action was not posted in the
prominent place in a prominent place. Children did not have daily
access to all interest areas. Uh, a teacher or assistant teacher
did not directly supervise an aid. Children were not placed within
the correct age category. The program violated the requirements
for using an unqualified substitute. All staff did not complete
ongoing training
All violations and
correction documentation was submitted and approved. Okay. Do
you know what? I I get a strong sense that something is going
on here. Okay. I'm getting a strong sense
there's somebody at the center of this or maybe two or three
somebody's at the center of this that is teaching all of these
people how to do this and filing all of their paperwork and getting
all of the things fixed when stuff gets [__] up.
You know what I'm saying? There's like one person who is like
dealing with the government and like just a fixer and they're
going to make all of this stuff work and they're going to go
fix all the things. Okay. Licensing investigation in March of
2025. Let's see the violations here. File, fire, and safety codes.
The floor plan did not contain all required items.
Program practices. Staff did not supervise the children at all
times. Program practices. The program was not operating within
the terms of the license. Now, what does that mean? Uh, October
2024. C violations.
Uh-oh. Program did not report a death, serious injury, fire,
or emergency as
Now, if you're really schizophrenic, if there was a way to check
police incident reports from October 23rd, 2024 or around that
time, looking around this area, oh boy. Then you could really
start to cook with some gas there. Okay. Licensing review. See
violations.
These people be violating a lot.
Program did not submit a background study request to DHS when
required. Correction documentation submitted and approved. Children's
records. Children's files did not contain physical exam documentation.
Facility equipment and furniture were not in good repair. Facility
the program space was not clean. Infant and toddler care. Crib
mattresses did not meet. So how many times do you have to get
the same violations the next year to go and
like lose your business. This is a lot of Now I don't run restaurants
and I don't run anything for childare. Is this pretty normal
to have this many violations? Maybe it is. Conditional license
review. Conditional license
This is March 5th, 2024. So, this is a second one. Children's
files did not contain physical exam documentation. Children's
files did not contain all required forms. Children's files did
not contain immunization documentation. Equipment and furniture
were not in good repair. This program space was not clean. The
indoor air temperatures below 68 degrees Fahrenheit. Uh, what?
Hold on. What is that in Celsius?
68 FN C is 20. Oh, that's not so bad. No, that's still pretty
weird, dude. 19 I can do 19 sometimes, but that's pretty
That's pretty No, 19's pretty cold. So, is it a terribly managed
business that racks up violations or a scam with no actual kids?
I'm confused.
it seems to be. What I'm concerned about is is this a business
that actually operates this way or are they consistently getting
like held above water by somebody who's like holding their hand
through this process? Like I don't know that they have kids there.
I still don't know even with all these things. Although I'd say
in 2024 it seems likely they had kids there. Okay. Whatever the
incident was that didn't get reported. Areas used by children
were not in good repair. Program space was not clean. Hazardous
objects were accessible to children. Children's files did not
contain immunization documentation. Children's files did not
contain all required forms. The program did not develop an individual
childare program plan for a child with a known allergy.
Licensing action was not posted in a prominent place. The Oh,
these people were getting sanctioned
right? A licensing action. This is like, hey, we're under sanction,
right? For bro, how many times you got to sanction this place
to shut it down? Am I crazy? How many times do they have put
up that the license a licensing action is not posted in a prominent
place? You know what this is, right? with within the restaurant
industry. This is like when you get a health code violation.
You got to post that in your window so that people know when
they're going to walk in, they have to know, hey, this place
didn't do a good job. This place is actually being sanctioned
by the health department. You got to post that up for everybody
to see. Tim Walls is personally Well, I don't think Tim Walls
is doing it. I'm guessing that there are people close to these
people who are in government who like probably keep this [__]
running to some extent. Oh, this is this is crazy though that
they're this much. I would say they definitely took care of kids
at at some point. Licensing actions and malreatment investigation
Fine. Order. Uh, Simon Aden, authorized.
Okay, hold on. Stan Aon, authorized agent. When I looked up Albi
Kitchen, can we find Albi Kitchen? I couldn't find Albi Kitchen.
Um, can I find the license for this place? Oh,
this is interesting. Oh, this is the agent. Hold on. This is
not the
This doesn't say who the owners are, but I just noticed that
for the for the actual business though, the Albi Kitchen, this
is Vardosa Ali. If we remember the guy who was the son, was his
last name not also was it also Ali contact person? Farardosa
Ali bad sidewalk. Oh, this is about um this is about adding a
sidewalk cafe license for the actual restaurant.
Maybe this is somebody else entirely.
This place definitely real. This place 100% real. Was it Ibraham
Ali?
Ibrahim.
I thought it was Ali at the end. Okay. All right. Well, I mean
this is all this is all interesting. Wait, I did want to see
Wait, what happened to that kid, though? Jesus. Hold on. So,
dear Sam Simon Aden, the Department of Human Ser uh human services,
DHS, is ordering you to pay a fine of $200 for one background
study violation. Details of our findings were provided below.
Our next steps and your options are also detailed. Reason for
the fine. DHS is also issuing this fine based on your failure
to comply with the following background study
Uh when preparing for a license review, a DHS licenser determined
you failed to repeat a background study for a childare program
staff within 5 years of the staff's person's most recent study.
SPI1. Okay, so this isn't actually something that crazy. This
is them failing to do background checks on their own employees.
Okay. Conditional license. Fine order. Conditional license. What
is this one?
It's placing your license to provide childcare at Quality Learning
Center on conditional status for 2 years beginning June 8th,
2022. This means you must meet certain criteria, certain conditions
to maintain your license detailed below.
This order is based on your non-compliance with childcare center
licensing requirements. Details of our findings are also provided
below. Our next steps and your options are also detailed
to comply with it's all the failures they had. Chronicity, your
program received its license on October 17th, 2017. Since that
time, your program has demonstrated a history of non-compliance
with licensing rules and statutes. The information below summarizes
this history. Okay, hold on. Let's let's take a look at these
from 2022.
Staff were unable to provide the first and last names for most
of the children present. DHS licensers asked the authorized agent
for children's files. The authorized agents provided a bin with
children's records,
but there were several children present who did not have files.
When the DHS licensers asked the AA, the authorized agent where
the missing children's files were, she pointed to a filing cabinet,
the DHS licensers observed that there were still not enough files
to account for each child present. And when asked again, the
AA stated families bring them with them and when they go to the
or sorry, families bring them with them when they go to doctor's
appointments. On March or sorry, May 10th, 2022, when the DHS
licensers asked the authorized agent for children's files, the
authorized agents pointed to a filing cabinet that said the children's
files were that's where the children's files were stored. The
DHS licensers observed that there were not I need to make this
bigger so I can zoom out.
So it's like not as
the DH DHS licensers
observed that there were not enough files to account for each
children present or each child present and asked the authorization
to confirm that there were no other children's files at the center.
The authorization confirmed there were no other children's files.
An individual from another childare program but not affiliated
with Quality Learning Center, Inc. arrived at the center and
gave the DHS licensers another bin that contained approximately
46 children's files. Bro, this is a whole scheme. I'm telling
you, it's a whole just some other dude who was at a different
child care center came with all of the files that could possibly
apply to this. Dude, how many of these kids are duplicated between
the centers? How that's what I think is happening. Okay. I think
they're getting
totally skitso. Not not publishing this opinion for everybody
to see. I think there's a pool of kids that they move around
from these centers when they know they're getting visited. I
think they get a heads up on the visit.
All those kids know they got to go to that place for that day.
That is what I think. I think they're duplicating the kids around
in these communities to like go and just file for maximum benefits.
That's my opinion. Ivory Heckler says, "What
is this? What are you linking me? What are you linking me?
What are we looking at?" Uh, "Hi, I'm in Minneapolis today covering
the childcare fraud
>> Fantastic.
I love when stuff breaks on Twitter. Cool. every hacker. >> Okay.
Hi, I'm in Minneapolis today covering the childcare fraud allegations
with my fellow independent journalist Real Akamara
aka Kamar. Quality Larrying Center has fixed its sign. We have
kids. We already saw the sign fixed. We have seen kids trickling
into the childcare center today after allegations that it wasn't
used for childare. We're covering fraud in other parts of Minnesota
as well. Quite interesting. Stay tuned for to my YouTube for
the full report. The state of Minnesota announced this center
was closed. They literally did. They literally did, which is
interesting that they said it was closed, but then their licensing
actually says, hold on, this is the weirdest thing to me. Last
renewed or updated on January 1st, 2026. Next renewal date, December
31st, 2026. How did they travel into the future? SOMALIANS GOT
TIME TRAVEL NOW. How they filling out this paperwork and going
to the future? January 1st, 2026.
What are we doing? I do think that they must have classrooms
here. They must have had classrooms here for sure. I don't know
when the when did the restaurant open.
Can I find Oh, this was about them. This was them applying in
what year? No, this is not it. I'm looking for
the this one. Looking for this one. Okay. Institutional food
service at Oh, current license at location. Institutional food
service at Quality Learning Center.
Bro, I'm telling you, they cook all the meals at this place.
They're doing it all in one building. There's like somebody there's
somebody that they could find who helps these people who sets
up the the kitchen and the daycare center licenses so you can
do both. You can basically bill for your own stuff through a
business that is a actual kitchen. You can do the catering, right?
There's like somebody who knows exactly how you set this entire
racket up and just charges people like a percentage and sets
the whole thing up. That's what's going on here. I'm almost positive.
Right. And I'm guessing you get really wide ranging levels of
compliance.
No, it's not a ghost kitchen. It's not a ghost kitchen. We went
and looked at it. It's not a ghost kitchen. Um, this Albi kitchen
place. It's not a ghost kitchen. You can literally go and eat
there. It's like actually a place. Okay. Although it's only got
one table. They bake and stuff.
Eight seats. I again
I do believe that this entire thing is set up. Somebody tells
these people how to set it up. Okay. Reverse image search. This
one. This one I could believe. Wait, I can't uh go somewhere.
Hold on.
I can't get this to pop out as an image. I can't even right click
it. Very weird. Show me. Show me. Show me. What is this?
So definitely like a real place. Definitely like a real place.
real business that exists. I will say though,
like this this right here, if we pause right here, that does
look like they take up a decent amount of the inside and I just
do they really have like a lot of child care going on behind
this. Let's continue on. >> Open up >> and getting
Oh, did I I my time stamp, didn't I, to go find this? Okay, we're
going to a different daycare center, guys. We're moving away
from quality for now.
For now.
And we'll see what's going on in fraud. and we headed over to
George Floyd's neighborhood to expose more of the fraud taking
place. >> This place is called Future. >> Guys, if
you like the content, go ahead, throw a couple subs my way. Um,
if you like the content, okay, you can sub through kick 955 split.
It's really awesome. If you if you put the words exclamation
point, donate in the chat, you can get the links to buy TTS messages
for the stream as well. Don't forget the kicks. If you buy kicks
on kick.com, you get your TTS message read in a light nice like
Indian voice. So long as you pay I think at least 500 kicks I
think. >> Leaders early learning center >> and it's
licensed for 90 children and in fiscal year 2025
they received $3.6
million.
In fiscal year 2024
they received $3 million. So in two years they got $6.67
claiming they have 90 children. You win.
>> Macho, thanks for the gifted sub. Let's >> Every
day of the week, five days a week. >> These people are
making just about more money than NBA athletes.
>> And we don't. >> This guy kind of looks a little
bit like Hunter Avalone to me. You guys see it? I see like a
little bit of Hunter Avalone in this dude. I >> don't even
know if they're paying taxes, but we >> These guys make
more than NBA athletes. These guys make more than NFL athletes.
These guys make more than rappers. These guys make more than
R&B singers. These guys make
>> I wonder if there's a pattern there. Anonymous. Thank
you very much for the gifted sub. >> I don't know where
this money is going. Is it Is it Is it going to terrorism? Is
it Where is it going? But it's it's theft. It's fraud.
And the reason I'm involved is I want it to stop. I care about
Minnesota. I'm doing this for the people of Minnesota. I don't
make a dime off all this time I've spent on this. He just do
it for the love of the game, you know. I believe that. I believe
he does that for the love of the game. Okay. >> I put my
life at risk several times, but I'm determined to see this through
and to correct what is wrong. What is >> Okay, this guy's
over. >> That's rough. That's rough. That's really rough.
Actually, that last part I was like kind of be like he's just
a little bit of an eccentric guy. And then he said that last
line and I'm like,
I don't know. But I don't know about that one, man. >> I'm
doing this for the people of Minnesota. I don't make a dime off
all this time I spent on this >> this one. >> I put
my life at risk several times. >> I don't know about that
one, man. I I don't know about that one, man. Okay. You put your
life at risk several times. I don't know. I don't know, man.
I am
I don't know. But I'm determined to see this through and to correct
what is wrong, what is evil. here at Future Leaders Early Learning
Center. This building received three million over $3 million.
Hello. >> How are you? >> I would like to see if
I can bring little Joey, my son, little Joey here. Is there a
paperwork or can I check out the daycare?
>> Why can't I check out the daycare? >> My love
here. >> Okay, but if I can I get paperwork or anything
to submit my son, little Joey, to come in here to daycare? We'd
really like to put Joey in this daycare. We've heard great things.
>> Business card? >> No, I would like your business
card. >> we talked to you manager.
>> Okay. Can I speak with somebody?
>> Where where are the children at?
Are there children here today? >> No children? >> Why
are there no children?
>> Two of them. >> Would my son little Joey have
friends to play with here?
>> No. No friends for little Joey? >> Yes. Ah, >> dang
it. Well, have a great rest of your >> Thank you. >> So,
little Joey would not be accepted to that daycare. >> Joy's
still homeless. >> Joey's still looking for daycare. And
because little Smart Therapy Center LLC
Monday to Friday, 9:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m. They won't be here until
2:00. Okay, I'm trying to think. I'm trying to think. Or is this
a different one? Oh, sorry. This is a Sorry. This is a screenshot
from a newscast that they cut to. That's my my bad. My bad. My
bad. >> That dayare. >> Joy's still homeless. >> Joey's
still looking for daycare. And because little Joey couldn't get
into a daycare, we went to an autism center. As they have been
popping up everywhere as a rise of autism has occurred here in
Minnesota because of the government funds that they are receiving.
I tried to check my son Joey into an autism center. We've been
going to a lot of these daycare centers. We're trying to find
a spot for our little boy Joey, >> but uh we thought maybe
we could check him in the autism center >> cuz none of
the daycare centers are open. Yeah. And how many kids do you
guys have at this autism center?
I can't give you a number now. >> Like more than five >> probably.
Yeah,
>> Dude, I
Okay, there's two things going on here and I have two wolves,
you know, it's the two wolves situation. One part of me is like
I think the only reason they're looking into this is cuz they're
race baiting. Okay.
But then there's another part of me that I'm like, "This is all
shady as there is some absolutely shady going on here and a lot
of people are looking at these people doing the race baiting
and they're going, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Like, this can't possibly. All this is fake." I'm like, "Dude,
open your eyes.
Open your [__] eyes, please. Please, you don't really
know."
>> What do you guys think about like the fraud that's been
labeled on the autism centers here? What do you guys do think
about the fraud? How come the autism centers are popping up?
>> I can't answer. >> Are you a news reporter? >> My
name's Nick. We're doing a little documentary trying to find
Lil Joey a spot to put himself in one of these centers here cuz
there's He doesn't even have a good story. Like literally, are
you a news reporter? We're doing a video at where? Yeah, we're
news reporters looking for a place for Arsad.
It's like, okay, bro. >> Why are you asking us about >> the
fraud?
Is this is this Nick Shirley guy actually a secret Somalian?
Because he doesn't speak English so good. >> Yeah, because
we want to make sure we're going to legit business if we're gonna
bring our little boy Joey here.
>> This is not a Joey spot.
[clears throat] >> But that's our number.
But this is a we can't let you guys.
>> Oh, okay. Thank you. So, once again, little Joey, he
can't even go to daycare and now they won't even accept him if
he has autism.
I unfortunately
think this is a case where you
and by the way I'm not saying you can hang these people on this.
You can't like do anything about this. This should be left to
the government. But I think there's something systemic going
on here.
I really do. I think there's something systemic going on. And
I think they've got a whole racket for fooling the people who
would look into this. I I don't think this guy does good work.
I really don't.
But I I really think there's something going on with these businesses.
>> And again, no kids. Couldn't tell you how many kids
they serve. >> After being able to provide no evidence
of them actually being an autism center in a place where a child
could go, they shut the door and we headed to the next fraudulent
daycare center that was just around the corner. >> We're
on to the next location. We're still trying to find little Joey
a place to go to get some daycare. >> So, where we're going
now is a place called Super Kids Daycare Center.
this daycare center was shut down when it was called Creative
Minds Daycare,
and it had received $2.45
million this
uh fiscal year 2025.
They had to shut down because there were so many violations
and they went and they just reopened under a new license and
they renamed the center Super Kids Daycare Center LLC. >> So,
they got shut down then started another one >> literally
the next day. Creative Minds Daycare. $2.45
million got sent to this daycare center. We have
empty parking lot. We do have a bus here. This is different.
We'll see if we see anybody. I knocked on the door. Absolutely
nobody was inside. And once again, no children could be heard
>> So, David, once again, another child daycare center.
We have a bus out here. No one's inside.
Licensed for over 50 kids. No children anywhere but yet millions
of dollars every single year. >> So the sign says Creative
Minds Daycare. They got in so much trouble. They had so many
violations
that they had to shut down and they reopened the next day under
Super Kids Daycare Center. You see 3801 Portland.
Oh, is that what's going on? That they
Oh, bro.
Nobody's checking on this either.
Oh my god, man. >> 3801 Portland, which is where we are.
>> So that's fraud right there alone.
>> Millions and millions of dollars. And again, the kids
are missing. Where are the kids? >> You would think if
they had the same address that whoever's inside or working at
the capital here inside of Minnesota would just say, "Oh, maybe
that's a red
>> They just they just write the check. Human services,
they got to clean out the whole bunch. They're the ones who enabled
this fraud. How can you not
>> Okay, I got to I'm going to have to go cuz we I might
be with
lethal levels of autism looking into this now. I I'm actually
getting annoyed. Okay, so all these businesses are look upable.
Are you trying to connect these people together? Because you
should be trying to connect these people together. If you're
going to actually try to do this, I can't do this on stream either.
this the this irresponsible to do it on stream because it would
it would involve looking into all of these people and trying
to find like connections between addresses and names,
Why? Cuz then I I'm I don't want to pull up people's like names
and addresses on this stream or like uh like their phone numbers
and [__] on the stream. I just not good. Okay, but
I'm saying you would want to go and do all of this because like
I really do think there's something going on.
I I just regret that these people were so lazy that they might
actually help these people get away with the fraud. >> Not
look and say, "Wait a minute. This these two are registered at
the same address. Sweep for the Somali." Wait, I'm not sweeping
for the Somali. I'm actually sweeping for the racists.
I'm saying the racists have have come onto this and they are
basically astroturfing a campaign saying don't look into this
by being so incompetent. And that I have like a whole bunch of
people who come into my chat are like, "Oh my god, these people
are so dumb. This is this is nothing." And it's like, why do
you think that? Oh, cuz this guy's racist. You think it's nothing?
Cuz this guy's racist. You didn't look at You didn't listen to
anything that's going on. You didn't look at anything going on.
You didn't listen to anything going on. You're just like, "Oh,
that guy's racist. I don't want to hear this anymore." Why? I've
I had so many people who were here when I started watching this.
And the second I went, "Oh, I think there's actually something
here." Gone from the chat. Instantly gone from the chat. Don't
care anymore. Oh, you're not going to say everybody's racist.
Oh, I'm leaving. Bye. So goofy. on top of all the childare centers.
That's just only a small piece of the fraud. What other fraud
are they committing here in >> So, another major piece
of the fraud is the home healthc care industry.
Where we're going now is a building that has 14 Somalied home
health care companies in the same building. >> 14 of the
same healthcare companies in one building. >> 14 home healthcare
companies with different names in the same building. How bad
has Tim Waltz managed the budget here inside of Minnesota? >> So,
the last bienium we >> Man, I Dude, this is so stupid to
be doing the political thing. Imagine you go cuz like I'm I'm
seeing what they put out in this video and I'm already like putting
things together going like I think there's there's like a pretty
predictable pattern to how they're doing this fraud. Seems pretty
obvious to me.
And this 2 p.m. thing keeps coming up. 2 p.m. 2 p.m. 2 p.m. Could
you imagine if you went and st these places out and then you
basically said, "Hey, I'm like here. I'm I'm running a news story.
When are the kids going to be here?" You say 2 p.m. and you like
wait to see if they leave from one of the other daycare centers
and come to like this daycare center. You get like people together.
You go you go stick it out. You can pay people to do this on
Fiverr. Hey, I'm just paying you like record this place. I'm
private investigator. I'm going to pay you to record this place.
Because that's what I suspect is happening here is that it's
a small group of people who basically take their their pool of
kids and they're moving them between these daycare centers. But
like Yeah, because then you're like, "Oh, I'm waiting. Oh, they'll
come at 2 p.m." And it's like, "Okay, well, let's see if they
come at 2 p.m. You watch and see if they get moved at 2 p.m.
Boom. You got them."
What if it's all the owner's kids? Well, I don't know. That's
a different kind of fraud. But like,
but these guys didn't try to do they just like they just went
one time. This guy says he went a hundred times. That's not proving.
>> We had an $18 billion surplus.
This bianium, we have a $6 billion deficit. That's a $24 billion
swing in one bienium.
How in the world can you burn through $ 24 billion in two years?
This is how right here. This is a huge part of it. >> And
so would you say a lot of that is fraud that's taking place here
in >> Absolutely. I would say
better than 90% of it is absolute outright fraud. >> And
a large percentage of this fraud is from these healthc care companies
that are charging the state millions of dollars while they actually
aren't providing anything. In fact, the FBI just did a raid a
few days ago on a building similar to the one we about to enter.
And inside of this building, there were 14 of nearly the exact
same businesses offering the exact same services. Right here
you have a list of
>> Dude, I love Okay, I personally love
that Elon Musk is talking about this says this kind of fraud
is rampant. It's like, "Oh, Elon, how would you fix this? If
they gave you like complete control over the government's coffers,
how would you fix this? Oh, wait. They already did that and you
didn't do sh like how it's so easy to complain from the outside,
right, and just go, "Oh, this is this is all fraudulent. Everything
there's so much fraud going on." And then they're like, "Okay,
here you have you have wide ranging, never-beforeseen
authority to handle this problem. That's really hard. I'm going
to quit and then I'm going to keep complaining about the fraud.
To be fair, this is at the state level." Uh, some of this apparently
is at the federal level or people were saying some of it's at
the federal level. I didn't think so. Sorry, it's the skitso.
The skitso threw me off. He said it was federal funding. I think
it's all state funding. God, all of the healthcare companies,
loads of them right here. We want healthcare. No, it's okay.
>> Yes, we'd like to speak about getting healthcare here.
>> No, no, no. >> Why can't I get healthcare here?
>> No, no, wait, wait, wait. >> Warning. You are
under video surveillance. No trespassing, security, arms. This
is the strangest
place I've ever been to get healthcare.
Just a bunch of different places. Healthcare here. Healthcare
right here.
Another healthcare company right here. There are three healthcare
companies inside of this building right here in this room of
7C.
Now we have another helping hands home care LLC. Another healthcare
company present.
Now this could be
present help. This could be possible like three, four, five.
Like basically you all run home care. I DUDE
dude I need to talk. Did Really look at this? I'm I'm trying
to see if I can have a combo with Really at some point. I I just
got to see what other people think about this because I I'm getting
like such a different read than what I heard people say.
What I heard like anyone say. I'm getting such a different read.
Brain wants to debate you. Is Brain going to join in the Discord
or
medical plaza? So strange. Never seen before. Wait, but these
aren't Hold on. These aren't medical these aren't actually healthcare
facilities, are they? I I'm seeing home care. Wait, what was
the name of the businesses again? Let me see here. Logistic and
supplies. K Ah, K A K K K K K K K K A A Ah,
Itaska home healthcare. These are all home care, senior care,
right? So, this is all these are businesses
or a bunch of these are like better home health care. These are
home care things. This I thought was actually where there was
fraud as well, like specifically homeare fraud. of the healthcare
companies.
Loads of them right here. We want healthcare.
>> Yes. We'd like to speak about getting healthcare here.
>> No. No. No. >> Healthare inc. >> No. No.
Wait. Wait. >> Warning. You are under video surveillance.
No,
>> bro. I just don't understand. Why would you ever make
this video as just like a rabble rouser going around these places
when people could have just been investigating and like actually
taking notes on this?
This video is actually so damaging to any possible case that
could be made here. It's so stupid.
>> No trespassing, security, arms. This is the strangest
place I've ever been to get healthcare.
Just a bunch of different places. Healthcare here. Healthcare
right here.
Another healthcare company right here. There are three healthcare
companies inside of this building right here in this room of
7C.
Now we have another helping hands home care LLC. Another healthcare
company present help. >> Oh, sorry. We we're going through
all these again. My bad. My bad. My bad. >> And we're in
this building. >> We have so many. Who can we talk about
getting the best healthcare? >> I don't know.
>> All right. We will not get any healthcare here. >> David,
this is one. >> Which Wait, which one was that? I have
another helping hand home care LLC. Another healthcare company.
Present help right here. We're looking for the best rates of
health. >> Was this present here inside this
>> Why wouldn't you just go look up what they do? Like
again, so easy. Go look up present help. Go see what they're
licensed to do. Go. Can I find Where's the Minnesota licensing
thing? Can I look it up here? Department of Human Services. Would
it be through this?
Hold on. Let me see if I can look this up. Present Care. I'll
try to see if I can find Present Care here.
Present Care. Does that pop up? Nope. Present. Present Help.
Oh, Present Help. Sorry. Present Help LLC. That's this one. Okay.
Let's see what they're licensed for. And then we'll we'll see
what I should be asking them for questions. Present Help,
Home and Community Based Services. So, they're not going to have
health care there. They're not taking care of people. Adult companion
services. Homemaker, night supervision, restbite care in home
or out of home, individual community living support, individualized
home supports.
This is a place that does home care. That's taking care of old
people. All right.
YouTuber Nick Shirley accuses uh he was told which ones to go
to.
Wait. Okay. I I believe that by like this old guy or whatever,
but I'm saying why doesn't he know what questions to ask? Why
are you just saying where can I get healthcare? This guy like
why are you just saying where can I get
ask actual questions. Such a waste. Sorry, somebody linked something.
Give me a second. Give me a second. Wait, what is this story?
What is this story telling me? Demuth GOP caucus directed YouTuber
to Minnesota. A professor explained why it went viral.
Okay, this is this is a giga sweep video. Even if the GOP directed
them here, these businesses look shady. Okay, I don't care if
the GOP directed them here. I don't care if the GOP knows about
a scandal that looks bad for Democrats and they direct them there.
I don't care.
I need a better I need a better explanation for what's going
on here than um actually the GOP told us to go here. Oh, also
GOP caucus directed. Let's see what it says. Uh YouTuber travels
to Minnesota knocking on doors and accusing Somali owned daycare
centers of fraud. Minnesota House Speaker Lisa Demouth said Monday
that her caucus steered YouTuber creator Nick Shirley to daycare
sites in Minnesota. Those featured in his video, a widely viewed
video, have been part of a state administered childcare program
using federal money. Oh, it is federal money. There you go. Although
some recently had operations or payments suspended. The video
was shared by Vice President JD Vance. FBI director Cash Patella
said he is aware of the video and the FBI is investigating. Fraud
needs to end in the state. Blah blah blah blah blah. Okay, so
it is the house speaker in Minnesota who said this. Huber says
he's uncovering a new fraud in Minnesota, but media outlets like
KT KSTP reported more than a year ago about more than 62 investigations
into Minnesota childcare centers more than a year ago. In
January of this year, not more than a year ago, round about a
year ago. >> Governor Tim Walls and state lawmakers recently
pledged to crack down on fraud and state government programs
after scandals questioned their oversight. We got complaints
about the childcare assistance program and took a closer look
at some of the daycare centers receiving millions of your taxpayer
dollars. And we found reports of violation state investigators
called a threat to the safety of children. Sorry, the video.
Here's the issue, Koko. The video is not legitimate journalism.
The video is garbage race baiting rabble rousing trash. Okay,
that's what it is. But the video itself is being based on a real
issue that seems to be that you can see symptoms of that issue.
And what I get out of the video is anger at how shoddily it was
put together at how a job they did putting the video together.
But it seems like a lot of people have been talking about this
problem. It's been a persistent problem in Minnesota for a while,
right? >> At centers that
>> No, no, no. It's racist to go in rabble rouse with this
video when you could just not be a lazy. Hey, this guy's Hey,
esoteric log. This guy's representing you as part of the white
race. Why is he so dog [__] at his job? Isn't he
supposed to be an example of excellence?
This guy sucks.
Why didn't this guy stake out any of these places? Why didn't
he just watch? You could watch this business. Hey, why are people
working in this building and four people who don't work here
come and go? Literally, not a single person goes into that building
that doesn't work there. Why the [__] do they have
all these office fronts?
Super easy question to ask. Super easy question to find out the
answer for like how many people are going in.
Did he do it? No. Okay. All right.
Like it's dog. It's total dog. >> Continued to receive
those federal >> Jay Cole spent months looking into these
issues and he joins us now with what he's found and a story you're
seeing first on five. Jay. >> Yeah, Lindsay. CCAP is a
$34 million state program that receives federal funding. It benefits
more than 12,000 low-income families each month across the entire
state. Learning of growing concerns about the program from sources
at the capital, I started looking into some of the daycarees
receiving the most money. Despite many serious safety violations
over multiple years, they continue to receive funding. And now
some state lawmakers want an investigation into what they call
a lack of oversight of the CCAP program. I started by visiting
quality learning center daycare. So, it is that 14B >> which
sits right in the heart of downtown Minneapolis between 2019
and
>> Oh, we caught it in the middle of the transformation.
They're they're turning this into the restaurant. They're turning
it into Albi. >> So, it is that 14B >> which sits
right in the heart of downtown Minneapolis between 2019 and 2023.
the Minnesota Department of
>> Again, I'm seeing I'm seeing where there could be holes
here where
I can I'm seeing where they do a slight change to the address.
They apply with somebody else's name and despite all the violations,
they could like get a new license or something, right? Like that.
Oh, well, now we'll use this for the restaurant or something.
I Dude, I feel like there's a lot of >> violations at this
location. They range
>> uh those locations he went to were already under investigation
and he was told which locations to go to which explains why he
seems so incompetent but happened to show up at places that seem
legit shady. Oh, sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You're right. You're
right. That the the state lawmakers like clearly literally all
you had to do is get shown this, right? This is literally everything
you need to know about Quality Learning Center. Bro, this these
people are doing the work I did. Like the first thing you should
do to put in your video, the first thing you should care about
is looking this business up and seeing what they got like cited
for. And >> failure to keep hazardous items away from children
to no records for 16 children, which include things like immunizations,
emergency contacts, and medical needs. So, state investigators
placed Quality Learning Center on a conditional license in 2022.
I went to the daycare's location several times, and only once
did I see people there. >> Oh, that's your daycare. But
I did not see any children. >> So there there are 80 kids
in there. >> No, not no not
>> after school. Okay, gotcha. All right, thank you. >> DHS
declined an interview, but in a statement acknowledged Quality
Learning Center was put on a conditional like >> Oh, hold
on. That could make sense that these businesses don't really
operate between like if you have a daycare, it's possible you
don't operate between
9 and two, right? 10 and two, right? It's possible. I could see
that that you don't operate between 10 and two. That basically
like you take kids in in the morning, kids who like basically
have parents who have to start work like earlier than when school
starts. So you do like an hour or two of childare in the morning.
You have some younger kids who stay longer between these periods,
right? But if the kid is in school, the kid's going to go to
school.
That's how daycare works, right? You have kids who are going
to be in elementary school. They go to elementary school around
8:30, 9:00 a.m. And then after that, yeah, well, lots lots of
places you don't really run a daycare center without doing children
like toddlers and infants because otherwise you don't have another
business to run, right? Like you just have way too much time.
But I could see these places that if they don't have toddlers,
yeah, they like bounce out for from like 10 to two and then go
back. license because of its poor safety record, but it still
received nearly $8 million in taxpayers money since 2019,
its conditional status removed in 2024,
bro. How did they get their conditional status removed? They
just consistently violated over and over again. How'd they get
their conditional status removed? How'd they get their license
back? They they had like a hold on the license. They had like
extra scrutiny and then after consistently failing every single
checkup, they got their license. They they took the conditional
hold off of it, the conditional thing off of it. >> I also
went to yet another facility, the Minnesota Child Care Center
in this South Minneapolis building. I found it at the end of
this small hallway with a steel door, no windows at
>> um No, they were dinged for lots of stuff. Private Huff,
we just went and looked it up. They were dinged for all kinds
of [__]
Uh that's not this one. Where is this one? They're dinged for
lots of We We looked them up earlier. I'm not going to pull them
back up right >> No visible security cameras. >> That's
the sign.
>> State records show between 2021 and 2023, the daycare
had 36 violations, some of them serious. They failed to request
initial background checks on six staff in 2023 and failed to
request repeat background checks on >> Okay, here's another
question.
Do they really have six staff there? Do you guys remember how
they were doing fraud back here in Minnesota? Back ah
with um wait, where is it now? This guy you they said here they
were basically hiring a ton of parents to come and work there.
That was like a part of the fraud. Okay. They really need six
people doing child care in that one building. And that's just
six employees. That's just the ones they didn't have background
checks on. How many other employees did they have that they did
have background checks on? That should be a part of this is how
many employees does that place have? that tiny little place that's
also a kitchen. How many employees do they have? Crazy, man.
Sorry, back to the investigation. >> Staff in 2024. Ultimately,
the state would accept corrective documentation on these violations.
>> Wasn't anybody here last time either? >> I visited
several times and each time no apparent sign of any workers and
each time no apparent sign of any children. >> Think there's
anybody there. Since 2018, Minnesota child care center, however,
received 11.5 million dollars in CCAP money. I asked DHS why
daycare centers could still receive millions of dollars with
questionable safety records over multiple years. In a statement,
DHS said, "Under state law, they can only stop payment, quote,
when a provider intentionally gives false information
or submits false attendance records. A provider is operating
after a suspension or revocation of its license. There's a credible
allegation of fraud andor a provider refuses access to attendance
>> What does that say to you? >> Um, it says that
the oversight is
>> I want who's cross who's
attendance
That's what I want to know. Who's attendance records
>> I shared our findings with House Speaker Designate Lisa
Damon. >> Are we keeping kids in Minnesota safe? And what
you're showing me here brings that very >> Oh, this is
the person. This is the person who gave the heads up to the Tyler
Oliver clone, Nick Shirley. the question. You know, Jay, you
have pages here that are publicly available
uh with repeated failure to keep hazardous items away from children,
failure to maintain adequate staffto child ratios, uh background
checks, um failing to keep
I'll be real,
I'm actually starting to get to the point I'm I'm going to I'm
going to start veering off into Republican territory. Okay, I'm
right there. I'm right there where I'm like, how much of like
the failure to to actually sufficiently punish these businesses
came from like, "Oh, me don't speak no English." Like at the
door, how many times How many times were they like, "Oh, me speak
no English." And they're like, "Oh, you poor little im you poor
little woman. Okay, I'll I'll, you know, I'll let you off the
hook this time."
I I'm almost there. I'm like getting there. Okay, I don't want
to be there. Don't put me there. But people have been complaining
about this for how long? >> Personnel files. Um, these
are repeated
>> As I was looking into the daycare center violations,
I also found a connection between CCAP and the feeding our future
scam which built $250 million from the
>> Oh, like the obvious connection you found? like the
obvious connection where these places were in 2019 doing catering
for their own kids with businesses they owned and they it's all
the same pool of people who all work at the same place. Really?
It's like the same thing's happening again. Shocking. >> In
2023, a man named Abdekadir Kadaya was charged with stealing
a million dollars in taxpayer money in the feeding our future
case. He's waiting to be sentenced after pleading guilty to wire
fraud. But we also learned Kadaya also operated into childc care
center in Minneapolis. The facility received $1.8 million in
taxpayer funds between 2017 and 21, >> but the license
was revoked at Kadaya's daycare was shut down. He has not been
named or charged with any crimes connected to CCAP. However,
now I've been asking for weeks why Kaday's license was revoked.
Late tonight, DH sent DHS sent over this 86page document explaining
why. Some of the more serious reasons include violations directly
related to the health and safety of children and providing false
and misleading information to DHS. DHS also told me they have
62 active se Okay, I I need to start looking up. I need I need
numbers. How many
What is the size of the
Somali population in Minneapolis?
What is the size? Because Minneapolis isn't that big, right?
Like I thought this the state of Minnesota is not that big. Yeah.
Mid 20,000s to low 30,000s. How these guys running like 50 daycarees
in the same place. It's Dude, like the scale has to absolutely
tell you that something crazy is going on here, right? The scale
is staggering. It It's It's
>> Decap investigations for >> Okay. No, sorry. I
I'm thinking Sorry, I'm comparing it to the other thing, the
the 90 fraud cases or whatever. I'm mixing some stuff up. I'm
not sure that the scale is wild yet. It does seem concerning
though. I'm seeing concerning patterns. Okay. Very concerning
>> Family child care and child care centers. And as far
as the two daycare centers in our story are concerned, I reached
out by phone to the names and numbers listed as the licensed
operators and I've not yet heard back. So, some new information
that there are now 62 active investigations into that program.
>> I'm speechless.
>> I I'm angry enough hearing about this that if I lived
here, I would just organize the stakeouts myself.
I would just organize them myself. And I would say, look at how
how many people are going into these businesses. There's no way
that these businesses can be functioning if the state doesn't
cross reference all of these businesses.
You're a [__] you you are insane. Because again,
what I'm suspecting is when I hear the story about the person
who, oh well, we investigated quality learning center and they
brought 42 files for 42 kids over from this other daycare center
that was unaffiliated
and that actually then we had all the this things for the kids.
That right there to me, I'm like, oh, like obviously
obviously something's going crazy. Something's very strange here.
I'm I'm not even
I I'm gonna maintain Rodmus Prime that this could just that this
could be any immigrant population anywhere on the planet that's
like kind of insulated and they figure out like some scheme that's
working and I I'm willing to bet that it started off like they're
actually just going to run childcare centers. Hey, you can run
this stuff through the government and we run our own kids here
and we can have our own kids here and we it'll all work. It all
be good. And then slowly they realize the edges and could how
they could defraud it, right? And maybe eventually it gets into
more highcale fraud. I don't know, ask other African countries
what they think about Somalians. I don't need to. You know what
I do? I treat this as if it's like a an amorphous blob and then
I just try to look at the facts
cuz if if these people are actually defrauding the government,
I don't need to know the color of their skin or what country
they're from to know that.
Fun fact. You can just figure that out. And it doesn't have to
just be black people who do it. It you can just figure it out,
man.
You just figure it out.
Although I will say there's a little bit here where like I I
think people
they think it's like racist to point out that immigration like
um insular immigrant populations can form sort of enclaves that
that do the same practices, right? They'll find a way to make
things work in this new place and they'll all do the same thing.
Yeah, absolutely that can happen. Which is why I would think
this would be pervasive. >> It's a lot of money. >> Yeah.
And this is just breaking tonight. >> Correct. Yes. We're
going to stay with it obviously and see what happens. >> Dude,
this is Dude, this is the racket though, right?
Go find the actual Oh, man. How hard would this be on YouTube?
Okay.
Brand new brand new game plan, guys. I'm going to go to a whole
bunch of local I'm going to take the the biggest three cities
in every state in America. I'm going to go to their local YouTube
channels, okay? Their local affiliate YouTube channels. I'm going
to look for local journalism they do of like big big stories
in those areas. And then we just go make videos, YouTube videos
on those exact stories. We just go to the exact same places,
do the exact same thing. You just get like some looking zoomer
who's totally danced out to go, "Oh, that's crazy, man. Oh my,
I need a place for Lil Joey. Can you give me a place for Lil
Joey?" And then you Yeah. Easy. Easy. You make it tie into race.
You make it tie into um immigration populations. Easy million
view videos. So simple, man.
You're just describing true true crime channels. Yeah. Well,
except for racism. Now, true crime for racism.
Easy. >> Next. State lawmakers have told me that they would
like this before some committees. As soon as they can get the
committees together, they want to bring it to some committees
and start investigating and looking into it a little bit deeper.
>> Uh here's what I'm getting. Here's what I'm thinking
here. Uh, Vanera, I'm thinking this is Giga Turbo Astroturfed
and that people are saying like this. Okay, people are saying
I didn't even know what JD said at the time, but I'm getting
the idea that JD is doing this because
this will be like the um they're eating the cats and they're
eating the dogs thing, right? We know there's actual fraud here.
What we want to do, and by the way, this is why you got to keep
your head on a swivel.
What I'm going to do if I'm a smart person, I don't want to just
point out the fraud. I want to win. I want to win political power.
And so what do I do? I get a racist YouTuber to go cover some
that I know is happening in a Democrat area. And then I get all
of the Democrat influencers to come out and go, "OH MY GOD, YOU'RE
RACIST AND THAT'S NOT EVEN TRUE. Oh my god, you're like racist
and you're just making this up." And then I get to go do a super
cut of all these.
So easy. So so so so easy, man. All right, I think we're finished
with the ABC investigation >> again involving our children.
>> Yeah. And tax day payer dollars. Lots of >> Lots
of again Jay's been looking into this for months. >> Yeah,
a long time. Stay on, >> man. Jay.
Damn. Oh, look at homeless industrial complex in San Francisco.
I'm not going to do that right now, but dude, it sucks cuz like
this is the kind of thing you you need. This is the kind of thing
where I get like super archaic. I'm like, dude, take the hands
of all the people who did this, okay? As well as like like putting
them in jail, but take their hands.
>> Like, it actually needs to be understood that if you
get caught doing [__] like >> you get caught
stealing. This is the only thing you can't do fraud on is the
government. That's what it should be. Okay,
this is the same reason I don't want the Trump people to get
away with it. Um, Ro, thank you very much for the gifted sub
to Flamma 50. That's why I don't want the the government to get
away with it either, dude. Holy hell,
Holy hell. It's like so bad when it's the government getting
stolen from. It's like everybody. It's They're stealing from
all of us.
>> Nearly 2000. >> Okay, hold on. We're done with
this. We're going back to the Tyler, not Tyler, Nick Shirley
video. We'll finish watching this and then I'm going to watch
some of the Asmin Gold stuff cuz Asmin Gold was going through
his whole thing talking about all this today >> building
because we have so many options. Who can we talk about getting
the best healthcare? >> I don't know.
>> All right. We will not get any healthcare here. David,
this is one of the stranger places I've ever been.
>> Literally healthcare every door you go to. Yet, nobody
will give you a rate. How much money do you think's been funneled
through this building? >> Every year I would say 50 to
60 million at least. And finally,
>> okay, but I again
government should be going and following up and and I think the
issue is out of those businesses, do any of those businesses
serve the same person? That's my concern. Do any of them serve
the same person? >> We were accepted into one of the daycare
centers and they actually took down information to give us a
rate. However, when we left, we were then met with the police.
I uh we received a complaint that
no one matching your description were in this building harassing
the individual to >> see this is another thing I suspect
I suspect this is why you got to be careful with like what you're
alleging
cuz I promise you there are going to be some people in that Somali
population
we're going to see that they're getting money to do a service
and they're going to faithfully provide that service right to
the best of their abilities they're going to take that money
and they're going to build a business with it and even if there's
Even if it's like the Somali community directly,
right?
Even if it's the Somali community directly, you don't want to
over the people who are actually trying to take that government
money, provide a service, make sure kids are taken care of, and
do a good job of it, right? Like this business. I'm sure there
are a couple of these daycarees that don't get a ton of citations
that aren't constantly like being written up, right? He has his
undercover investigator sunglasses on indoors so that no one
knows he's being sneaky. Well, actually, those those glasses
are literally Yeah.
They're literally video cameras.
>> Stay here. >> Oh, we're just seeing we're checking
out the rates for healthcare because there's 14 healthcare companies
inside this building. So, okay. >> Well, that's not what
he said. He said there's 14 companies here and he's trying to
assume because they're Somali providers, everyone here is fraudulent.
>> He's here with some kind of like >> No, we're
just checking. >> No, this is this >> is this person
Asian
There's there's always some Karen at one of these places. Leave
the Somali alone. Leave the Somali alone.
>> Did I say Wait, did I not say Filipino? >> Where
is this? >> I see you. I see you. Racist
side eye and the racist. See you. This is Ju gangstalked legal
mindset. No. No. It was old white women. That's who gangstalked
legal mindset even though he was in Thailand. >> This is
a um
area that we're allowed to enforce trespassing ordinance. Is
there any other reason that you guys are here? Well, we were
checking rates. >> No, he's not. >> We were checking
rates. We asked for >> No, you're not. >> Okay, I'm
gonna have If you guys are all good, we're going to step outside
and we >> All right, let's leave. So, all right, we're
getting escorted out right now. The police have arrived.
We checking out the rates, seeing what was happening inside this
building. No one would really speak with us. We did go inside
the one daycare center and she actually did give us rates for
childcare. Much respect to that lady. What's the problem, officer?
Well, so again, we're we've been getting reports from there now
multiple individuals that you guys were harassing individuals
who are work
>> At the end of the day, this is private property and
it's one that people are allowed to ask you. >> Wait, is
it
is it the property owner who's asking him to leave? If this is
a business center, is it the property owner who's asking him
to leave or is it one of the private businesses? Yeah. Is it
one of the private businesses is asking him to leave?
I don't think the police get to kick him out. I
do. You think this guy's smart enough to know that? Almost >> And
it's also when the Minneapolis Police Department is allowed to
enforce trespassing ordinance at this address. >> Yeah.
So, >> as we got escorted out of this building, the Somali
filmed us as we left and we headed over to the next building
that had 22 of the same home health care providers operating
from inside of the >> Right here you have Multicultural
Home Care. And right here, it says it's open, but can't even
get in. Another Reliance Recovery Center. Mercy and Grace Care
Inc. Right here you have Denden Eratrayan Youth Development Association.
>> Area represent. Let's [screaming] go. It's not just
all Somalians out here. It represent. Let's go. >> of Minnesota.
Another
>> should probably say Eratraa, I think is how you say
it. >> Childcare center. Welcome to Bright Beginning Center.
But what do you guys think about the fraud that's taking place
here in Minnesota? >> Sorry, no comments. Can I please?
>> Right here you have Serenity. >> He didn't want
her to complain on video about him holding the door open with
the spoil, which he's clearly doing, right? >> Can I please?
>> Right here you have Serenity quality care. [laughter]
All these businesses are literally the same type of business
providing the same service in the same building. Another convenience,
home, healthcare, aid, Inc. and child-friendly space. All these
companies get money from the government. Why would you have the
same company essentially inside of the same building doortodoor
right here? Queenly Home Healthcare. It just does not make sense.
If you were trying to operate a business, you'd want to have
less competition. But here, they have all their competition right
next door. We're wondering cuz we hear there's lots of fraud
taking place here in Minnesota, and we're wondering why is there
so many of the same companies inside of this same building? >> No,
I don't know that. >> What do you think about the fraud
that's taking place here in Minnesota? >> I don't have
any idea about that fraud. Okay, that's it. >> What do
you think about the news articles and what's being spared on
the news about the fraud >> right now? You are doing something
>> I'm just asking you. >> No, you don't have to
ask. >> Okay,
this guy's doing the the ABA voice. Where is that from in Africa?
This is like the Why are you gay? >> The voice. >> Don't
ask me that question again. >> Okay. Okay. >> Who
can I speak to? >> Who can I speak to?
>> Okay. As soon as you confront about the fraud, they
get angry. When these people have these home healthcare companies,
you're seeing them. I mean, you're you're there accusing them
of fraud everywhere inside this building. What kind of fraud
are they committing? >> So, there's false documentation
being submitted to the state of Minnesota for services never
provided.
Uh they're having >> Can we see that that that one I'm
like, "Oh, that would be fantastic if you showed me any of that."
Can you show me any of that? Or do you notice how like that's
the big It sucks when it sucks when the biggest claims are totally
right? Like I can tell something weird's going on here, but then
he says this and I'm like, "Oh, I would love to see the information
on that." And are we going to see it? >> Forms signed for
services that were then never rendered as far as a year or two
years in advance. They'll have someone sign these forms at one
sitting and then they just file those with the state of Minnesota
and nobody from the state of Okay, that's Hold on. You got to
be careful. Okay, cuz there
there is fraud that happens.
I'm going to confess to insurance fraud right now. Okay, when
I was um
when I was in high school,
I injured myself playing football. I like tweaked my neck and
I went to a massage therapist, right? And because I was going
to a massage therapist and it was covered under insurance, I
got them to write me some scripts for massage after that. Okay.
And then I gave those to my mom and my mom was able to charge
those against her own insurance that covered me and so she got
to go for more of whatever she was cover, right? That was actual
insurance fraud.
But like that'll happen. And I don't even care that that happens.
get insurance companies. Okay. A little bit. A little bit. But
all what I'm concerned about is like not getting, you know, four
extra
massages in a year or something. I'm not concerned about that.
I'm concerned about people who are straight up not doing anything,
right? Like straight up just faking even providing the service.
>> Minnesota bothers to check that those services were
ever provided. So they're essentially just using people saying
that they had these services provided months or even years ago,
then filing the paperwork and then receiving money from the government,
>> right? And the Somali community is a very closed community.
So everybody's in on it and they don't want to talk as you can
see. >> And for this building, I'm going to give an estimate
of around $30 million for how much fraud is taking place. That
is a very low estimate. However, still a lot of money in fraud.
>> And do you think there is fraud taking place here? >> I
don't know. Yeah. Do you have any idea what any of these businesses
are doing? >> I never ask. >> And now with upwards
of $100 million in fraud, we'll be headed to one more daycare.
And this one gets a little spicy as we get chased out at the
very end. And after this, we'll be heading to the state capital
to confront the incompetent government leaders who have
>> It just feels like they're trying to start a pgram.
Well, here's the thing. Here's the thing. Okay.
a year ago, you got this really nice ABC report. I seem to have
closed it actually, but you get this really nice ABC report naming
some of these same businesses showing that they're like, I think
pretty clearly fraudulent. Okay, there's something going on where
these businesses aren't trustworthy. They're getting to keep
their license after they're getting their license back after
endangering kids like a bunch of times. Very strange stuff. Okay.
And and when you get the ABC investigation where this guy's talking
about it, like that's asking nicely.
I don't I don't know. Like it seems like if we just need YouTubers
to go out and make it like a race thing so someone will look
into it, that sucks. But why don't you do your job without, you
know, having it to have it get >> This fraud to happen.
>> And I knew this video was going to be super dangerous
to film because of obviously how hostile it is and as we are
exposing legit fraud happening. I did get security for this video
and I was able to do it through the Blackline Guardian. And if
you guys want to help fund my security in the future, you can
go down to the link down below. They're not paying me to say
any of this. They came and decided to help me out for the video.
So you can go to Blackline Guardian, the link's down below, and
click Guardian for Nicknick. And those funds will directly go
to my security in future videos as we are exposing lots of things
happening, especially with this fraud. Like I said, they're not
sponsoring this video. So, I'm just giving them a shout out because
of how they helped me. So, go down the link down below, click
Guardian for Nick, and let's keep going. And now we're going
to the next location. >> Now, this child daycare center,
this one's different than all the other ones we've been to. Tell
us about this one. >> This one is different because according
to the state of Minnesota, this 312 West Lake Street houses not
one, not two, but three child care centers and is licensed to
hold 102 children. And in fiscal year 2025
was paid 2.6 66
million by the state of Minnesota. >> And this is the building
right here. So, this building alone made $2.6 million.
Let's see if anybody's inside. Now, we're inside of the building
where there's apparently four childcare centers. We met this
lady and we followed her to the back of the building where the
daycare was supposedly at. >> So, right here we have two
child daycare centers. We have the Minnesota childcare center
and then we also have Nuna. Between the two,
2.66 million. Hello.
>> Why are you recording? >> Yes. Um, we would like
to know. >> Well, it says we're trying to figure out 102
children. Is that for this facility?
>> What? What is the name? >> It's from the state
of Minnesota website.
It says you have 102 children here in your child care. >> Which
name? It's a lot of >> Minnesota childcare right here.
It's from the state of Minnesota's website. >> We're just
wondering where the >> This looks like a legitimate childare
center. This like some of them don't. Some of them look like
straight up warehouses
like where you take the kids, right? When you're a serial killer
with kids. That's what a lot of the other childcare centers look
like. This one actually looks like they got kids in there. I
might believe that. >> Children are
>> Where are the children now? >> Yeah. Where are
the children? It says you have 102 children here. >> And
you got $2.66 million this year in
>> and $2.5 million last year. We're just wondering where
the where the kids are. >> And who are you? >> My
name is Nick Shirley. Nick Shirley, >> where are you? Where
are you?
>> That is harassment. >> Oh, we are from ourselves.
>> Hello. We'd like to ask where the money's going.
>> Look at that. Shut us down. Where are the children at?
No children inside of this daycare center. And look at this daycare
center right here. No. Hey. Hey.
Where are the kids at? Show me the kids. Where are the kids?
I just want to see the kids. I Yeah, I know I'm just a YouTuber,
but I just want to see the kids. Can I see the kids? Can you
show me the kids? It's like, uh, no. Yeah. Well, go away. >> Children
inside of this day center, but between those buildings, over
$2.6 million.
We were just curious, where are the where are the children at?
Do you know where the children are at?
>> Where are the children at in these daycare centers?
>> I don't care. >> Where kids at? Where kids? I'm
here for the kids. Where the kids at? I'm here to purchase a
child. I am here to purchase a child. >> How come these
childare centers have no children? There's $2.6 million inside
businesses that were given by the government, but there's no
children to be seen anywhere. People deserve to know where their
taxes are going. If these companies and these daycare centers
are making upwards of $2.6 million and there's no children to
be seen anywhere, something fraudulent is happening. And that
is not make you racist, islamophobic.
This is just the truth of what's happening here in Minnesota.
If there's a bunch of white people doing the same thing, we'd
be talking about the same issue. This is just fraud at unprecedented
levels here inside of Minnesota. It's actually very concerning.
Where are the children at inside of these buildings? They're
nowhere to be seen. Millions of dollars are being sent into these
daycare centers all across Minnesota. And there's not a child
to be seen anywhere. Here's another daycare center inside this
same building.
>> We don't want you to be videotaping
>> Where is all the money going for if there's no children
at these daycare >> sir? Yes. >> I told you please
leave. >> Yes. We have a question though. Where is the
children at these daycare centers if there's millions of dollars?
>> Ask the local government. Yeah. >> Oh, we've asked.
We have the paper here. So, we're wondering where the money and
where the children are at. No, we have the paper right here.
Come here. >> Who are you? First of all, >> my name
is Nick Shirley. >> You don't have any permission to record
me. Period. >> Can we talk outside? >> You have permission
to record? She doesn't either have she doesn't have permission
to record me. >> You cannot stop people on the street and
question them. >> We can ask. >> You don't have any
permission. >> Where are the children? >> I will
sue you. >> You literally can. You just can't hound them.
You can totally
How does I think conversations work? >> Hey. Hey. Uh, your
shoelace is untied. YOU CANNOT STOP ME ON THE STREET AND ASK
ME QUESTIONS. YOU CANNOT do this. No, I totally I'm talk to you,
but you'd also tell me to [__] off. That's fine.
That's >> You don't have any permission. We have nothing
to do with this. >> Then are there children? >> So
leave. Please leave. >> Are there children here? >> Please
leave. >> Where are the children? $2.6 million for a daycare
center. >> You ask who? >> Now the thing that I feel
like could happen here is does not feel like a comet pingpong
situation could be going on here. I I feel like once you make
these people once you villainize these people sufficiently,
I feel like this guy's just here with a video camera. I feel
like we're 2 seconds away from something somebody showing up
in a way more deranged way.
That's a little concerning. But man, I don't know how you talk
about it. I think the way you talk about it is you provide like
an open and shut
and it's so easy. Hey, we we staked out these businesses for
a week, two weeks even. Okay, we staked out a bunch of businesses.
You might even spend like weeks putting this together, but it
would be worth it. You could make this so airtight,
But instead of making this like totally airtight, you just go
and like fight with people and make it you you sensationalize
it maximally. Daycare got broken into yesterday was on the news.
Yeah. Yeah, I would expect that.
Now I you can just you I understand lefties would be like, "Oh,
these racists are getting these innocent Somalians harassed."
Nope. Government's doing that again. ABC investigation was 11
months ago. 11 months ago was the ABC like B the ABC investigation
basically like announcing this, pointing it out and nobody's
done anything. How has nothing happened? It seems like until
somebody makes something like this that blows an issue like this
up, it just doesn't get looked at. It's so stupid. Um, so we
watched a video of basically these guys went to the quality leing
center or whatever. We watch ABC News in Minnesota a year ago,
go to that same place, point out all the same issu same issues
and more. Is there concrete proof proof for any of this?
I mean,
there's concrete proof that these places are like somehow continue
to get funded despite being like terrible at taking care of kids,
like having tons and tons of violations. Okay, there's proof
that they're clearly uh getting licenses for capacity that they
can't possibly fulfill, right? They're licensed to take care
of like 99 kids in a day and they've got like two kids there,
right? Or sorry, they they couldn't have more than like 10 kids
there.
Quality Learing Center. Yeah, exactly. Why are you guys saying
I'm literally telling you what the proof is? Why are you saying
not in the video when I'm telling you what the proof is? I've
been doing this whole time. This whole time I've been going and
looking at other sources of information.
I'm not just watching this video. Don't say just the video. No,
this video sucks. Whoever you think is doing that, you don't
know what you're talking about. So leave. Leave. >> Tell
us what's happening here then. >> I said leave. >> We're
wondering what's happening. >> We are not a child care.
We are nothing to do with you. We're common people walking and
you are >> We're not We're not accusing you. We're asking
where are the children are at. >> Don't ask me anything.
>> We're not accusing you. We're asking the daycare centers.
>> I am not going to answer. You have >> Where are
the children at? >> Leave. Leave. >> We just want
to know where are the children. who who you work from.
>> Uh, Sims Hoy, you're just you're just wrong. You're
literally just wrong. Go read some of the Go read the documentation
for the people who actually like went and investigated these
places. Go and read what they actually found. Not based on this
video
months ago. Months and months and months ago. My name is Nick
Shirley. >> Who do you work for? >> I work for myself.
Nick Shirley. >> Okay. What are you recording? >> We're
wondering where are the children? 2.6 66
million for >> you're not talking >> the Minnesota
childcare center. >> You're not talking to the right person.
>> Are there children that come here? Answer the question.
Are there children? >> There's no children inside this
>> I don't know who you talking to me. >> That's
just a simple question. Where are the children at? David, they
won't even answer. We asked him plain and simple. Where are the
children? Do children come >> This is why I've had my life
I've been attacked twice.
uh once with a knife and the other time I was jumped last Saturday
by three Somali men simply for asking questions about what was
going on. And I mean they're very
>> Watch this guy simply asking questions so far and it
was pretty aggressive for simply asking questions. Okay, I'm
not shocked when he like walks up with the papers. He's like,
"WHERE ARE THE KIDS? WHY ARE YOU DEFRAUDING THE GOVERNMENT? WHERE
ARE THE KIDS?" I'M I'm not surprised. I'm not surprised that
some people don't like that, man. >> Very violent people,
they do not like this fraud to be exposed. >> After giving
this man plenty of opportunities to answer the simple question,
where are the children? He called the cops on us and we headed
to the state capital where they're having a meeting about the
fraud to confront the state representatives and people in the
government who have enabled and let this fraud happen. Inside
of this committee, a Republican representative showed charts
showing exactly how this fraud has been committed and who is
profiting. Oh, see this is real though.
This is real, right?
Oh,
he won. Oh, dude. Can I see this? Um, Minnesota House Committee
Fraud and Oversight.
Um, Minnesota House Committee
Fraud Oversight. Can I see this? Yes. Oh, they do it. They do
have this stuff on YouTube. Let's go 13 days ago.
Yes, this is the same thing. >> Moving on to adult day
services. A bit more about um the second >> Can you see
is the guy here? Can you see Nick Shirley somewhere here? Where
Nick Shirley at?
Is that That's not him back there, is it? I think you should
see him. He should be here somewhere. Hold on. Where's
And connecting all the dots. And while the Democrat representatives
looked into the Bird,
lesbian chic is not in right now. Okay. Why are you trying to
look like an actual lesbian? Is Steve Elkins Benjamin Brinks?
Maybe Benjamin Brinks. >> One of them spoke about how none
of this is building trust and how this is a nonpartisan issue.
So I went and confronted her after that. >> He he has some
very valid questions to ask about what's going on here in Minnesota.
And do you think this this fraud crosses My name's Nick Shirley.
Do you think this fraud
>> gray gray sweater? Do we see him sitting here somewhere?
No, he'd have to be back here. This would be where the audience
is, right? These would probably all be legislators around the
the round table. I don't see No, he's not here in his gray sweater.
I think this is the same thing though. >> I will just be
your paint.
>> Reban Ruben donated $3. The cord molecule map is way
better than that
>> Wow. Very cool. There's here's I just saw the lady that
he's interviewing. It's this lady, right?
Oh, maybe this is a different day.
We can we can definitely find this though. And I will find this
cuz we'll go watch this and see what the actual evidence is,
right? For sure. Oh, no. That's not the same lady. Wait, is this
even the same place? Now that I'm looking, is it even the same
place? Color. Oh, it's just color correction. Maybe it's got
to be the same place.
Yeah, maybe it's just color correction. Yeah, it's just color
correction. like the same panels, same size panels
going on. This is just color corrected weirdly. Oh, this is the
lady right here. And then this is the lesbian guy. So, yeah.
No, this is the same day, same place. Okay, let's finish the
video and then we will >> spoke about how none of this
is building trust and how this is a nonpartisan issue. So, I
went and confronted her after that. >> Yes, but he he has
some very valid questions to ask about what's going on here in
Minnesota. And do you think this this fraud crosses My name's
Nick Shirley. Do you think this fraud is Republican or Democrat
or just facts that fraud is happening? >> So just now they
>> I think the fact that they as a partisan >> well
because that's what I heard you talking about. >> I know
what I said is that when we're >> we want to build we want
to build trust but fraud is fraud. So why should we be enabling
fraud to happen here? >> No, I don't think anybody is enabling
fraud to happen. >> Hold Governor Walls accountable for
>> Okay, sir. >> No, no, no.
>> Dude, these people suck so badly. Oh, this is sir. When
are you going to hold Governor Walls? No. No. Representative
for the state of Minnesota. Yes or no? >> Um, excuse me.
>> Are you If you're going to talk to me
>> I heard you and I got a chance to testify. Thank you
for testifying today.
>> the facts are the facts that fraud is happening here
and it's not a nonpartisan issue.
>> How come you think fraud has been able to happen so
much underneath? I think if you've been listening to our test
our hearings, we've had now
>> 10 hearings on this and so there's really good data
from the people who both work within the administration as well
as who um both Democrat and Republicans. I think what you heard
today is that the Republicans who control this committee are
not actually interested in solving fraud. What they're interested
in is telling a >> This fraud has happened underneath Democrat
leader Tim Waltz. Um there has been Medicaid fraud across the
country under Democrats and Republicans. There's fraud within
the Trump administration. There we we have is fraud.
Public private providers have made government a mark. And so
every person running government, Democrats or Republicans are
dealing with the issue of how to keep fraudsters out of our public
payment. We're also dealing with veterans. We're dealing with
uh consumers. I hope you're looking at that. If you look at United
Health currently is being charged with defrauding Medicare, you
know who runs Medicare? President Trump. Medicaid fraud is a
50-st state issue. >> And so again, it is not a partisan
issue. There are Democrats and Republicans who are sitting in
that committee talking about it. But what you did here was the
Republican chair say she's not turning information over to the
one person in government who can stop payment. And I hope you
print that.
>> Thank you for coming. Did I
>> this state of Minnesota that we live in and these politicians
are just walking
off thinking it's okay Tuesday, >> dude. This guy. Oh my
goodness. >> And they want to go visit the Trump. They
want to blame the Trump administration. We have Democrats blaming
ICE. I'm tired.
My people are
I'm scared for my little brother. >> Dude. Dude. What the
Who is this guy?
Who is this guy? >> My people are suffering and these people
just walk off. [laughter]
>> Dude, WHAT? >> MY PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING. >> DUDE,
WHAT? People are suffering. Oh, there's chocolate pain. I do
think there's a little taande there, but he's darker. Okay,
dark taande.
AND THESE PEOPLE JUST WALK OFF.
We have a governor who doesn't care how many more people are
going to freaking
>> I I legitimately feel like this guy is he's obviously
acting, but I feel like this could be acting on the level that
this like Yeah. Okay. Okay. Uh I feel like this could be acting
on the level
like is he is he a double scop here? Is this like a is this like
a left-leaning guy who's just like a theater kid?
I
dude [laughter] dude the faces, man. The faces.
Uhhuh.
How many more people are going to go
And how many more people are going to be trafficked in our freaking
system? >> Freaking system.
Oh, okay.